Good.
We never know how to start these things.
This is never like,
never feels like it has thing podcasts like a conversation.
It has to get a ball rolling.
It's not like a song.
They get kick off with a good jam.
I need,
uh,
we need momentum.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast brought to you by
squarespace.com.
squarespace.com is a,
it's a website that we highly recommend.
If you want to make a website,
you don't have to go to someone and get your website made anymore.
You used to be dead.
I've,
I've had every single one of my websites made by someone who knows what the fuck
they're doing,
but you don't have to do that.
Now I've actually messed around with this and created a website and cc to do.
Brian is created a shit load of them.
Why?
We've done the actual show itself.
It shows you how to do everything and you don't even have to enter your credit
card to try it.
If you're like,
Ooh,
this ain't going to work,
just give it a shot.
Fuck around with it online.
And if you're not into it,
just close the browser.
But if you're into it,
you enter in your credit card information and you can just take it live and you
can also start your own store.
Online stores are stupid,
easy to do.
And the way it's set up,
it's basically point and click.
If you know how to use normal normal programs,
like if you can open Microsoft word,
if you can go to a website and navigate your way around,
you can figure out how to use Squarespace.
It's stupid,
easy,
choose from over 20 bad ass designs.
They have 24 hours,
24,
seven super fast email support and live online chat support.
It also works with everything.
And if you make a website or work on an iPhone and a work on Android,
it work on all the different browsers on computers to go to squarespace.com and
if you use the code word Joe and the number nine,
all one word,
Joe Nine,
uh,
you will save 20% for a limited time.
I think that's just till the end of this month,
which is like tomorrow or something.
Right?
So,
uh,
if you hear this today is September 30th,
no,
this,
that,
that probably only works for a couple days after that.
Yeah,
maybe,
well,
hopefully they'll,
but it will be that,
but I don't know if they get the 20% off because it's normally a 10% off.
They doubled it up anyway.
That's it.
Go there.
Do that if you want or don't,
it doesn't matter.
It's all going to be good.
We're also brought to you by it.
That's it.
That's the beautiful thing about high numbers.
You know what?
There's no,
no high pressure in your folks.
There's plenty of us out there.
Some of us actually need to make a website.
Um,
but here's something we could all use because let's be honest,
most of us are dumb as fuck.
And there's a website that tries to help you with that.
It's called Lumosity.
And the idea behind Lumosity is the same idea behind exercise is use your mind
and use your mind in very specific ways.
If you just exercise like a knucklehead,
you don't know what you're doing.
You're not going to get any results.
The best way to get results at an exercise is to engage in a program that's
specifically designed to make your body work better.
And that's what they've done with the human brain.
They've created a bunch of games and these games are so specific that you
actually can enter in different parameters.
You get started and they ask you,
okay,
like what,
what are your memory?
Are you trying to improve?
Whether you were trying to recall certain,
uh,
certain names,
whether you're trying to learn new things,
whether you're trying to keep track of several ideas at the same time.
So he entering which one of those things applies and then the next step
attention and you can,
it says improved productivity concentrate.
And based on what are these things you check,
like maybe you don't give a fuck about maintaining focus.
Maybe you're just one of those dudes as gangster about that.
Or maybe you don't give a fuck about a reacting quickly.
You're just a laid back guy.
If you do though,
they have it set up for speeds,
speed of the mind,
speed of decision making.
And it all comes out in games.
And what they've done is essentially set up a bunch of fun games that you can
play.
And these games actually increase your memory,
make your focus,
your,
your mental speed better.
Make your,
your focus more in tune,
better problem solving.
It's really kind of interesting.
I just started fucking around with it and,
uh,
I feel exactly the same.
I'm not going to lie to you,
but it's,
it's early.
I mean I'm a thickheaded dude.
It's going to take some time to,
to make me smarter.
But uh,
but I'm into it and it's interesting and a,
if you go there say that you heard it from me,
Joe Rogan and uh,
I don't know what happens.
They hook you up or something.
Maybe they,
they say thanks man.
And one for women.
I don't think so.
I do not think so.
I think it's entirely,
but,
which is probably a good idea,
right?
Cause men and women's minds have been proven scientifically to function better.
Uh,
and who would know better than you?
Both sides of the coin.
You can tell us exactly what the fuck's going on.
Um,
so go there.
Go to Lumosity,
check it out and tell them that Joe Rogan sent you and you'll enjoy it.
It's a,
it's interesting I'm using it like I told you guys that I would,
uh,
update you along the way.
And uh,
like I said,
I'm not any smarter in exactly the same,
at least I don't think.
I think it would take time.
Maybe I am.
Maybe you think I am.
Maybe you're going bro.
Joe,
you're being hard on yourself.
You feel smarter already this show.
If so,
thank you.
All right.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n,
I t.
And this will be the last commercial.
I feel like,
what the fuck dude,
you just some sort of a capitalist just trying to get paid son.
Uh,
go on at.com and check out all of the things we have to offer.
The way we best describe on it is,
is a human optimization website.
We try to make available for you.
Everything that we enjoy me by me and we uh,
I mean Aubrey,
um,
and myself and all the folks that uh,
that own on it,
the way we have it set up is anything we find that's good.
Whether it's the best,
um,
hemp protein powder we can find whether it's the,
the best Himalayan salt or killer bee honey or MCT oil use,
like we sell the bulletproof stuff because we're,
I think his stuff is the best.
I think he has the best coffee and I think he has the best MCT oil.
I've listened to his philosophy on acquiring products and I,
I believe in it.
So we just sell his shit.
You know,
we try to find the best stuff that we can get online as far as strength and
conditioning equipment.
Well there it's battle ropes.
We end,
we tried to sell them to as reasonably as possible.
We're not trying to rip anybody off and improving of that.
All the supplements on,
on at.com,
like a shroom tack and Alpha Brain.
They all have a 30 pill,
90 day money back guarantee,
which means if you try out for brain and you go,
you don't want it to sit and you didn't do shit for me,
you get your money back.
You don't even have to send the pills back in.
Like the idea behind it is to make sure that nobody feels ripped off.
The last thing I want is anybody feeling like they get fucked unless you wanted
to get fucked.
You know what I'm saying?
People go to [inaudible] dot com use the code named Brogan and save 10% off any
and all supplements.
We've got a lot of cool shit,
including the,
the new primal bells,
which are all kettle bells.
Um,
by uh,
John Shubin Juniors.
That's the same,
right?
I said,
God damn,
I'm terrible with these fucking things.
I want to say somewhat Mr Shubin Mr Shoe,
but I presume,
yeah,
they're pretty bad ass.
Well,
they're made by a,
um,
a real artist.
Stephen's Shubin,
Steven Shubin.
I want to say it's Steven.
Wow.
Fuck.
I keep forgetting I'm terrible at names.
Um,
yeah,
the gorillas,
two pood,
which is a Russian measurement of weight for Kettlebells at 72 pounds and the
orangutans 54 and the chimp is 35.
These are all balanced out too,
so you can use them.
They're actually functional,
not just cool looking.
They should put one with your head on it.
Maybe.
Maybe I could be like 60 pounds,
but people don't want to commit to the gorilla.
But uh,
they have big fat handles are,
they're uh,
they enhance your grip strength.
We,
we made them as good as we can for actual use.
I use that chimp all the time.
And I,
I,
I use a gorilla to,
for a power movements.
Power movements.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's it.
The end on a.com codeword Rogan,
ballade fucking blah,
blah,
blah.
This weekend I'm at the Ontario Improv.
That's an Ontario,
California.
Don't be freaking out if you're living in an Ontario,
Canada,
cause I was just as air.
We were just at in Toronto,
you're Fox,
but a,
that's this weekend I'll be at the Ontario Improv.
Then October 18th I'm at the buy you music center in Houston,
Texas.
Uh,
it's almost sold out.
There's only a,
I think there's like a hundred tickets left or less.
And then a dance house theater and Manchester,
England on the 25th that shit sold out.
And then Irvine Improv on November 1st,
second and third.
That's an Irvine,
California.
All right.
That's it.
That's,
that's all we got going on.
Fuck angels here.
We're going to,
we're going to party.
Excuse me.
Music Chamie Bogan experience.
Try my day.
I'll get podcasts all day.
You were saying that's serious
stuff you have to talk about,
like your sponsorship is serious.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
That you have so much sponsorship.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
There's a lot of sponsorship.
Too much probably.
We're probably whoring it out right now.
Probably hitting the whore threshold.
Well,
it helps.
It helps to get,
it motivates you to do things too,
but it's all good stuff for it.
Yeah,
it's all good stuff.
We make sure that I've definitely turned down more things than I'm accepted,
uh,
for podcast sponsors because it's a lot of them just no sketchy or,
well,
you believe phonics.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Everything that we have,
I use and that's the point.
Yeah.
Or if I wouldn't use,
I believe that I would use it if I had a situation like stamps.com I don't use
it,
but if it came up,
I'd use it.
Or the website builder.
Exactly.
I'm saying,
well,
hey man,
thanks for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
I appreciate you coming by.
It's really cool it for you to have me on.
You know that is it.
You know how cool.
It is a huge,
I try not to,
I try not to be aware about.
Cool.
Anything goes.
You just stay as a,
even as mellow as possible.
Some people are very scared,
so they won't go there.
Oh Man.
Do you know what?
I think people are more scared of themselves and they are of other things,
especially on a minute.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a lot of that going on,
right?
That's a weird thing with humans.
We're all,
first of all,
we're all afraid of the great beyond.
We're afraid of the abyss.
At the end of this journey,
which we were all face,
everybody's fucking terrified of that.
And,
and,
and being terrified of that,
you also open yourself up to a series of other terrorists.
The accept because you have the primary terror that's always tick talking and
you don't want to think about that primary terror.
So you ignore that primary terror with a series of other terrorists,
whether it's you're worried about homos or immigrants or blacks or Mexicans or
Canadians or Russians,
it's always them.
It's always somebody who wants to take my guns or someone who has guns.
You know,
it's this,
it's either someone who's moving into the neighborhood or there's always people
wallet.
I mean there's,
there's also the problem of there's too much information coming on a daily
basis,
right?
You know,
there's fucking 7 billion people on this planet and we're just inundated with
horror stories like all throughout the globe constantly.
Every day,
the grossest shit is a shift that we're going to pay attention to the most,
the most horrifying stories in the news,
the ones that we're going to,
they're going to get the most clicks.
So,
you know,
the old adage,
if it bleeds it leads,
but I think people are interested in that.
That's why they do that.
Because people get excited to hear that crazy bad news or else it wouldn't be
the number one news.
Well,
I think it's because it's a part of,
um,
our,
our past,
you know,
and it's also like what got us to,
to be in 2013 the first place is by being scared of everything and staying
alive.
You know,
breeding,
keeping,
moving,
staying alive,
being terrified of anything that can hurt you.
But these things can really hurt us.
They could hurt us if we're there,
but we're not there.
We're not,
we're not right next to the volcano as it goes off on the other side of the
planet.
Yeah.
But they're touching on that fear.
And then that fear comes up with whatever you just said.
Any of those above mentioned things.
And then all of a sudden you're like,
ah,
yeah,
right.
I mean I kind of did that when I moved out of the United States.
I'll be honest with you.
I would imagine so kind of,
it was going to ask you if we could talk about that,
cause I didn't know if you wanted to,
I'll,
oh totally.
You live in,
in Mexico now?
I live in the Yucatan in Mexico.
That's pretty dope.
What happened?
Well,
I mean I was living in New Orleans and Hurricane Katrina hit.
I remember and I was really disappointed with the way that things were going and
I really just saw like,
well I live in this country,
don't get me wrong.
I,
I'm an American.
I'm totally cool with that.
I like being an American,
but I was really having a hard time with the government and just everything that
was happening that really kind of set me off.
And I was like,
what is going on in this country?
And I just started looking for other places to live because I just saw a future
that was not going to be positive for me.
And what did you see those positive about Mexico?
Well,
the Yucatan,
what I felt was that I could go live there and nobody really,
I felt first off my work and the adult entertainment business was being attacked
by the Bush administration.
Not a lot of people really know that situation.
Did you freak out when like Max Hardcore got arrested?
The jail.
That was,
that was scary to me.
And I'm not a pornographer.
Yeah,
exactly.
Thank you for saying that because even though you're not a pornographer,
that's still something that could affect you in the long run.
Well,
not only that,
it's like,
I don't like what he does.
I don't like,
I've seen some of the videos of shirts mean nasty,
cruel,
weird,
tortured type Shit I've seen.
He opened up this girl's ass and Piston and it's Tuck a strong,
it made her drink out of,
it's like,
it was so,
it's so gone.
I don't like it,
you know?
I mean,
I think it's creepy and the guy's a creep for doing it,
but whatever.
But there's a here,
you have to understand them as a businessman.
Right.
And so,
um,
he's like feeding the customer.
I agree.
I agree with you in the fact that it's not my thing,
but I'm not going to judge.
Right.
I don't like to judge,
so I don't like to judge either,
man.
It's like I was having this conversation with a friend of mine about,
um,
about bondage and like women who would like to get tied up and I'm like,
look,
you can't deny that people like that.
Like if you're a strong woman and you are,
you,
you're kind of a control freak and you run a business and you can imagine
anybody ever fucking tying you up.
That's okay.
But that's just you totally like there's somebody out there that loves it.
There's people that love it,
live for it.
They take pictures on Twitter of their rope marks on the real live for it.
Yeah,
they love it can tied up.
They like getting abused.
There's people that actually enjoy it and you know,
I guess maybe it's a fantasy thing for some of them it's consensual.
That's the key that people need to understand is the,
it's consenting between two adults.
So when you get to that weird area where someone is sort of like deciding what's
moral and immoral,
it's so
clearly at it is,
I mean it's,
I have played those kinds of games.
I'm very into that,
this leather scene in playing certain kinds of games,
but you have to understand it's me and that other adults saying,
this is what we want.
Most of the time it's a negotiated,
right.
I would never do something that you didn't want me to do to you or vice versa.
Right.
It seems twisted,
but it's twisted in our own kind of fun way.
Yeah,
and what the fuck is wrong with that?
What's,
that's a weird thing to decide that there's something wrong with two people
doing what they want to do.
That doesn't even involve you.
Thanks for saying that,
but it's weird that that there's a certain group of people that will just openly
do that,
that will openly try to stop people,
stop people from marrying each other just because it has a lot to do with
religion in this country.
It's sort of organized religion,
I need to say.
It certainly does.
And what does that embrace that embraces the fear,
the great answer of the fear,
the fear of the great end of the abyss.
And if you don't do it,
we're going to do where it would tell you to do.
Rather you're going to burn.
And internal inferno.
I'm already there.
Internal Inferno.
Um,
are you though?
No,
I'm just kidding.
It's impossible now actually.
I think they're there.
They're there while they promoted.
That's the real strange thing to do to people.
I really think that fear and that like if you don't listen to what we have to
do,
but the fact that so many millions of people get sucked into it.
What's that?
I have theories.
Okay.
Oh my big one is that religion is a sin and language itself is essentially like
a pit stop on the way to the unification of the human minds and that we still
can lie and that's a real issue.
And we also understand what what is convincing and we understand like when words
come across well,
so because you can tell me a true story and it can move me and you can get a
very powerful reaction out of me.
You can fabricate a story and say it as if it was true and get that exact same
reaction because we can't read minds yet.
So because of this,
this weird sort of adolescent stage did we have right now that were existing
where we're,
we're not quite evolved enough.
We could read each other's minds,
but we share a form of telepathy communication with our non verbal telepathy.
It's basically,
if we're honest,
you're explaining to me and I'm kind of getting a sense through the words and
the definitions that I've got in my head of those words.
I'm kind of getting a sense of what you're saying.
Some reading and you can tell me stories about your past.
You can express to me how you feel about things currently.
I can see it from your point of view,
as long as you're being honest.
But when you start all of a sudden realizing that you don't have to be honest,
and then realizing that you can kind of manipulate things.
And what,
what is the quintessential preacher?
It's a fire and brimstone man who speaks like no one,
you know,
someone who speaks from the word of God and stands on that stage and nose look
to when they die and the spirit of the Lord moves me and they talk like a way
that you never talked and it's so in and powerful that it just,
it's just a power thing.
It just becomes a power thing.
It becomes a,
the ability to manipulate and to move people with these lies.
And so you just kind of person.
Yeah,
because I don't get manipulated by it.
Neither do you.
Right.
But I could have,
I did when I was young,
when I was really young.
I mean I was,
I went to Catholic school when I was in first grade and that's what cured me of
it.
I had an evil Catholic school nun and the school was just so dark and just a
void of happiness.
There's a,
there was no hat.
It was empty.
It was just a depressing,
I mean it made me worry about the future of life.
Like before I went to that school,
I was like a happy kid.
I thought that life was going to be fun.
And just one year with that cunt and all the other evil fucks that we're running
that school and just seen kids get.
Peyton was six and you first felt that at six years old.
I remember that very clearly.
Very clearly that religion was horse shit right away.
I was like,
oh,
this is all bullshit.
Like this isn't real.
These are all crazy people.
Cause I could tell being six that these were all just a bunch of maniacs is evil
lady who liked to yell and scream at kids.
She used to like to scare the shit out of you and tell you that she's going to
make you sit on a nail.
He sit in the,
he,
she's going to make you sit in a closet on a nail and you're gonna make you
bring,
you better bring your pillow,
cause you're gonna sleep here and you're not,
you're never going home.
Like she knew you wanted to get out of there so she would torture you until you,
That con UN see that is weird weirdness that is like unconsensual as the nanny
children.
Yeah.
That's a good,
that's a good way of looking at it.
Yeah.
But I think it started out with that.
It started out,
they probably,
you know,
it probably started out if you,
if you really think about how much is good in Christianity,
love your brother,
treat others as if they were yourself.
The,
the,
the core tenants of Christianity about just the,
the work of Jesus.
How he always was with the dregs of society and he didn't judge people at all
and he tried to heal the sick.
All the things that are positive about it.
You've got to think that there's some,
some basis in religion is like things that people learned that really connect
you to the happy life,
to the good life,
which is the life of love,
the life of caring for each other.
So they figured these things out.
But then in writing them down back then,
especially like it wasn't until like the 15 hundreds of people read the Bible on
a regular basis.
Most people couldn't read it.
There was a,
you'd have to be like a scholar or you had to be someone who understood Latin or
somebody could read Greek.
The,
the,
the people of the common folks of the 15 hundreds they,
you know,
that was what the big Martin Luther thing was about.
It was Martin Luther was the first guy to create like a phonetic Bible that
people could actually read.
And they were like,
wait a minute,
this is not what we thought it was.
And that's what spawned Lutherism.
Like their view of the Bible was completely different than what they'd been,
and it made a huge issue because the church was trying to control who had access
to that information.
Right?
Because if you had access to that information,
you could tell people,
hey,
this is what God wants you to do and you have to listen.
Right.
And now all of a sudden people were able to read it for themselves.
And so that took one layer of power away.
So we're,
we're dealing with today is the most enlightened version of religion the world
has ever known.
It's still a fucking crippled mess.
It's a total mass.
It's scary.
It is scary,
but runs most of the world really.
Yup.
This is because most of the world hasn't caught up yet,
just like there was no cell phones and most of the world two decades ago,
I think two decades from now,
the idea of religion is going to be way,
way less common.
Way less common.
So I'm almost positive it's not the idea of God.
The idea of God will probably be more common.
Yeah.
Because people will kind of understand that the word God is real slippery.
You know?
[inaudible] you think as a dude in the clouds,
it's running everything,
but if you took that word away and what do you,
you know,
just express it.
Not a person,
not a thing,
but is there an energy?
Is there an idea?
Is there an ideal ideal way of,
of living the world?
What would be the godly way,
the godly way?
It'd be almost exactly what they say in the Bible.
That's what it's supposed to be like that they manipulated it because why did
they do that though?
I think because they wanted to start controlling the masses,
so they made it a different thing that I really want.
It is what's also,
how the fuck do you regulate people?
You know?
I'm sure if you're,
especially if you're a dumb person,
live in a few hundred years ago,
it's too hard to regulate people's too hard.
Again,
you get a thousand people in a room and every one of them wants to be the king.
Right.
You know like who the fuck is going to w if you have some information they're
not going to listen.
Now I've got my own information.
I'm starting my Scientology.
It's the new one.
I got it,
I got it all over here.
We got Mormonism is the shift what you guys are doing your trash.
Jesus wrote some new Shit,
you know and there's always going to be a new ego that wants to step to the
center of the line and control the room and because of that it's almost like it
was impossible to not have bullshit.
But if it wasn't for that religion,
if it wasn't for a bunch of people that were put in line and scared and this is
a terrible idea,
but I think it's probably true.
I don't think we would have made it this far.
Hmm.
I think people would have been way more barbaric.
Like there's enough control unless there's only two ways around it.
One is mushrooms.
If you gave me the mushrooms very young from,
from like an early day on and then that would probably eliminate a lot of the
need for it.
Look at certain cultures in the world,
like the Mayan people,
they used all of that kind of stuff.
I don't think that they were like freaking out on each other or had to do like
some major.
He freaked out each other a lot.
The Mayans,
they did a lot of human sacrifice.
Both really?
Yeah,
but I mean,
it's Alina word judging that.
Right.
We probably should.
We should do it now.
They killed the Mayan or the Aztecs when they built the,
the pyramid
of tio two ICAN,
I think it was.
They killed 80,000 people over a period of a few days.
I'll for days.
Yeah.
At some insane amount of painful information.
We didn't close the facts.
I'm like,
wait,
the Aztecs that killed all the,
when they at the,
upon the completion of the pyramid,
they killed all the slaves.
All the prisoners that were,
that were helping them build these awesome building.
They just cut their hearts out and fucking tossed them to the crowds.
I mean,
that's Kinda hard core,
but I don't think the Mayans were that hard.
Oh yeah,
they were.
Yeah,
they have.
They had,
if you ever go to Cheech and Eatsa,
there's actually like an hour from teaching you if you've been to the one where
you go to the temple and there's,
there's a fucking big table where they cut people's hearts out on,
it's like this,
this demon God looking thing.
And then he's,
he's holding up this table and that's where they would cool.
Carve people's fucking hearts out with,
you know,
big courts,
knives.
I don't know what the fuck they did with it.
And then there's also a lot of,
um,
thought that the Mayans,
much like almost every civilization from ancient Egypt on,
they start out really good and then everything just fucking crumbles apart as he
gets several generations in.
So is that human nature?
It could be,
right.
It's also,
I think what we're saying earlier,
I think it could be a part of this,
this uh,
inability to completely understand each other because the,
the,
the ability to lie through language and then also the,
the people that develop these ideas and work so hard to create this culture and
not the people that are born into it and enjoy it from the get go.
Sort of like kids that are born rich.
They developed this like really spoiled.
Like have you ever met someone who is like really intense and like super
focused,
like some banker type character but it's sun,
it's just a complete waste.
Broad.
I have cars.
Yeah.
Always,
always.
Even in Mexico there's that house.
If there were really bad in Mexico,
kids are out of control.
It's like they're all from Beverly Hills.
Like No.
Nothing to have to think.
They don't have to do anything.
So they have this attitude that everyone has their waiter or everyone is there,
you know,
serving,
they have that attitude there.
Wow.
Yeah.
The haves and have nots are much greater there.
The difference between money and no money is insane there.
Yeah.
And I had to get used to actually,
how did you choose the Yucatan?
Because uh,
we looked around whether they want him to live and then we realize it's only an
hour and a half flight from Houston.
It's like right across the water,
close to the United States because I work so much in the u s it's just like I
can commute to,
you know,
my work really easy and it wasn't a difficult situation.
Do you ever feel like in danger there?
Do you ever feel completely different than the rest of Mexico?
It's like its own like country really.
The actually wanted to separate from Mexico at one time and become their own
country,
but Mexico said don't even try it.
Really?
Yeah.
So it's really much different.
They're much more chilled out,
less.
There's no murderers.
There's nothing there.
There's no violent.
Yeah.
I live in the safest city in all of Mexico.
It's like we have no,
no violence or anything.
No kidding.
Yeah,
it's unbelievable.
I saw one thing on the news about some,
someone lit up a building on fire,
the Yucatan.
That's very rare.
Yeah.
It must be rare because it was the only time I ever heard about exactly.
I mean it happens all the time and the rest of Mexico cause it's completely out
of control.
If they legalize marijuana we would,
you know,
I'm sure you know Mexico's quietly decriminalized all drugs.
Yes I do.
It's kind of interesting isn't it?
Yes,
it is very interesting.
And they're smart,
very smart,
very smart country.
The government there is actually a little ahead of ours I think.
Real.
Yes.
And a lot of ways,
I mean they already,
gay marriage was way legal long time ago,
way before us.
I don't know how you feel about that,
but you know,
it's like so stupid that we're fighting about who cares who gets married.
It's a distraction.
I think it's a beach ball completely.
I think it's a beach ball.
They toss up and you sort of have to swat.
Yeah.
When you argue pro or con,
the important thing is to never resolve it.
Yes,
exactly.
I told the story in the podcast before,
but,
uh,
I,
I lived in San Francisco from age seven to 11 and my next door neighbors are
these crazy gay guys used to get naked with my arm.
They smoke weed and play song goes.
So I was around,
you know,
gay people at a very early age.
And then when I was 11,
we moved to Florida,
which is like the polar opposite of San Francisco.
And all of a sudden I had this friend,
this friend,
my friend candy and his dad was going crazy.
Dad at a newspaper was,
I can't fucking believe this shit.
He slams the paper down and we were like,
what's going on?
He's like,
these fucking queers want to get married.
And it was to him it was,
it was like,
it was something like that was infuriating.
It was really infuriating.
And um,
I remember thinking at 11,
I'm like,
you fucking baby.
What do you care?
Why would you care?
It doesn't make any sense that you would get angry.
Like how does that even affect you?
How does it affect,
how does it affect people and affect people?
Because it's a,
it's a germ that gets planted into the culture.
The idea that it's a problem gets planted in the culture and then it just
becomes something that people bring up and they want to think about their own
real problem.
Right.
It's the same kind of same thing.
Everything is everybody else.
Yeah.
Otherwise it doesn't make any sense.
I mean,
the reality of gay dudes is just like the reality of dudes.
There are nice dudes and there's dudes who will lie to you and try to fuck you
clearly.
And that's,
I used to work out at Gold's gym when I was on news radio and I've always said
that I felt like a tasty morsel case.
Do,
did you ever use the toilet?
I bet you did.
It pretty gangster get in there.
Um,
but it's,
it's all gay guys.
Like it's probably 80% gay guys and they grunting and sweating and it's very
sexual environment lately,
you know?
And for a lot of people,
that's a,
that's a horrifying place to go.
You know,
it's,
a lot of gyms are like that though.
There are grunting,
even if they're straight dads,
but it's still very sexual and this kind of way we don't really talk about,
by the way,
you should use straight in air quotes
because there's a lot of those hives.
Bodybuilder do as would be happy to suck a cock was sure.
You keep a secret.
Oh,
I see him all the time on it.
Yeah.
My friend Rodney,
he's gay.
He was always telling me about how many he would do straight.
How many straight guys have let him blow him.
Yeah,
because that's not gay.
Not Gay.
Was just leaving.
Amy and I only pay attention.
Barely even know what's going on.
Um,
whatever,
whatever.
If it doesn't come in your mouth,
it's on.
Cool.
Yeah.
As long as you come in his mouth,
it's like it's a wash.
It's a push.
Yeah.
Good dudes or creepers.
Dude's period.
Look,
I'm telling you,
I used to be a woman and I became a man and I'm telling you,
I think differently.
I react differently,
my sexual fantasies or differently and I get it now I get why men are pigs.
It's totally testosterone.
Testosterone is what created rape it,
testosterone created war,
pillaging everything,
all the above,
everything.
And,
and you know,
this is like a thing that I'm doing in my act right now about how,
uh,
the greatest warriors throughout history were gay.
This is what a lot of people don't realize in today's Day and age where there's
a separation between,
you know,
a gay and straight people that there's,
there's the CIC gay people and then there's the straight people that are just
living by God's way and that,
you know,
we got to keep these gay people from Mary.
And like everything that happened that got us into the 21st century involve gay
warrior.
Right?
Awesome Spartans,
Romans,
Athenian,
Samurais,
everyone was gay.
And that's one of those weird,
regardless of if you're gay or not,
like you,
like if you hate gay people,
you,
you literally have to hate,
I mean,
not saying that,
you know,
a lot of the shit of the Romans and the Spartans,
he,
they did some horrible,
ruthless,
evil fucking murderers shit.
However,
that's what I sort of got people into the 21st century,
right?
I mean that's,
they were gay people.
That's a fact.
But it's so weird to me that people are so concerned.
It's,
it's,
it's their sexual preference and it,
that's all it's based on.
So like,
I don't really care who you fuck.
Why do you care?
Why exactly.
That's exactly,
and that's what it should be.
Right.
But I think more men are weirded out by it then women are scared,
scared,
scared because they might be attractive.
What I might,
you know what I mean?
And so when I came along and I,
you know,
I,
I have a pussy,
so guys were like attracted to me,
but not sure.
That's straight guys and gay guys.
And they're looking fuse like what does that mean?
Am I gay or no,
I'm not gay because he has a pussy.
So that doesn't make me,
I'm like,
dude,
it doesn't make him anything about horny.
Just relax.
It's not really a big fucking deal.
But guys are like,
they're always thinking,
how can I,
not if I'm attracted to that,
am I gay or am I strange?
Well,
even that statement,
it doesn't make anything in the heart.
We relaxed.
That's a guy statement.
It's a guy statement and girl would never say that.
No,
they would go,
well you know you have to think about your emotional.
What do you have invested in this?
I read some thing.
I read something,
I tried to read it.
I blacked out from irony and logic halfway into it,
but it was a male feminist guide to dating a woman.
Some guy wrote this fucking Tldr,
too long didn't read and massive multi fucking step way to to be a male feminist
and date women and how to approach each and every scenario.
Like the biggest pussy.
What bitch?
And not even,
because not all women are the same.
Some women like to actually be like dudes and just go have sex and it's not
really a big deal and we have to be emotional.
Some girls are like that by them.
There's a lot of girls like that.
They don't really want to have all that emotional stuff though,
you know,
whatever it was.
But it was so specific.
It was so specific as to how you should deal with each and every situation and
you know how you should call after sex and make sure that it was okay and where,
where we're standing and I want to let you know how I feel and like,
do you know that is like the easiest way to get a chick to fucking never call
you again and you're like,
you need me bitch.
And I guarantee you the guy who wrote that has no fucking,
I like to keep a girl in his life,
but why does he think he knows that from?
Cause he probably has some dominant female voice in his life that he's trying to
placate some she demon that controls his testicle strings and he wants to write
to appease her.
Yeah,
I've written something I can attribute to your vagina and he gets to read it out
and look,
I'm,
I'm the most sensitive man who's ever lived.
I'm more sensitive than a woman.
I see your sensitivity coming and I check it with double sensitivity.
I totally know those guys will be Internet mocks them.
They're called White Knights and they shouldn't be.
They should be mocked.
I they called Whiteness.
Just because you can write a blog doesn't mean it's right flux.
You crazy ass internet right there.
When the electricity goes off,
you will starve to death.
You will not make it right.
You do not have,
I was married to a dominate tricks.
Those guys,
I know them.
It all now their world there.
What's that like?
Very strange.
Like really strict,
like you can't even imagine the kinds that,
you know,
it's all good.
It's consensual.
It's a trip.
A lot of those kinds of guys that are very into that.
Well I have a buddy,
my buddy Jim Norton loves that shit and we were at a restaurant once in Austin,
Texas.
This nice gal came over to the table,
started talking to us because she knew that he was into that and she's a
dominatrix.
So she started talking dominatrix talk.
She was very friendly.
So she was telling us like what kind of clients she has without revealing their
names,
of course.
But she was saying she deals with a lot of like really powerful businessman.
They run shit all day,
but then at the end of the day it's,
you know,
what do you,
what do you want me to do,
mommy?
Yes.
Mommy.
They call her mommy.
One boundary I have is the baby play like everything else,
but like baby can't steal it.
Can't deal with the adult.
Maybe you don't even think they were going with baby.
I think they were going to
was like complete week man who lives at home with his mom was screams at him all
the time and tells him what to do.
Like it was like he wanted to be humiliated.
Yeah.
Pipis pissing his mouth,
all that.
And also like,
um,
financial domination.
That's also a vague line really.
Were they like praying?
She'll be like,
bring $3,000 with you and cash all twenties and he shows that with $3,000 all
twenties and she goes,
give it to me.
And she takes it from him and that's like the scene.
Wow.
I'm like,
that's a good job.
You know what?
It makes sense.
There's,
it takes everything to make this thing work.
There's like there's Yin and Yang,
there's plus and minuses.
Every fucking little puzzle piece fits in together.
And imagine if you have the job of a,
you know,
corporate CEO and you have to stress out all day long.
I mean,
that's hard core.
You want to just go have a spanking after that.
I couldn't even imagine.
And to have millions and millions of dollars on the line.
Every decision every day.
Yeah.
I couldn't imagine.
I mean I've,
I've tried,
you know,
running a television show and it's fucking mom and that's just entertainment.
Yeah.
That's silly.
And,
and temporary,
you know,
six episodes and you know,
it's over at the end and still your free stress is like,
oh,
insane.
It breaks your brain.
I feel way different when I'm stressed.
My decision making's not so good.
I'm right too,
too edgy.
Oh,
like bark when I shouldn't,
I,
I won't think things through.
It's like,
it's just,
you're constantly you to keep yourself calm and how do you keep yourself calm
and focused?
Furious.
Exercise.
The only thing that gets it out of me,
it has to be heavy bag.
Like,
just beat the shit out of a bag,
do some kettle bell workouts,
run up a hill,
sprint up hills.
For me,
it has to be something where I'm fighting life or death because I think that
those feelings of stress that you get the,
those are life,
death,
struggle type things because it's incredibly stressful,
you know?
And I think those,
even if it's like something as silly as a television show,
if it's important to you,
you're going to get an intense amount of like energy focused on that.
I don't,
at least my body doesn't know what the fuck is going on.
Right.
And that those scenarios,
it thinks like we're going to have to fucking fight with swords or one from
dragons or we've got to do some shit,
man.
Right.
And so unless I blow it out,
unless I just blow it out to the point where my heart feels like it's going to
rip out of my chest,
then I,
I don't,
I don't ever calm down.
Yeah.
No,
I think I can relate to that.
Totally.
I feel so much more calm after I had a hardcore workout.
Or your body is designed,
you know,
our bodies,
the DNA of our bodies is from an animal that was running from Jaguars a hundred
thousand years ago,
200,000 years ago,
a million years ago.
There's this,
the same echoes of that primal time when we were so vulnerable and surrounded by
predators at all times,
including human predators.
You know,
I think that shit is just,
it's in our system still and took,
what about attendance?
Not Women had it run.
Two women had to fight.
Two women had to stay alive.
Women had to protect their babies.
I mean,
they didn't have to do it as much or often.
And of course,
the plus and the minus of testosterone is the minuses.
I mean,
they're actually proven that men with larger testicles make shittier fathers.
I'll,
yeah,
I did read that recently.
It's incredible.
It's so,
it's so cool.
They've also proven that men with larger testicles around women who are more
promiscuous and the more promiscuous the women,
the larger the testicles of the men in the community.
We'll have.
Oh Wow.
Because they produce more testosterone,
so they'll be more crazy.
Exactly.
And there'll be less likely to stick around and raise their children.
Whereas women who have much less testosterone,
they will raise the children.
It's almost like nature sets you up.
If you're going to be nurture,
you gotta be understanding and peaceful.
You want to be a calm thing.
You want to be a thing that doesn't have this fucking write up all the time,
ready to go,
you know?
And and men in that high pressure,
high stress situation like,
you know,
in the jungle or something like that,
are ready to go.
You've got to protect,
you gotta defend.
You got to hunt to get to the things have to be done on a,
in a split second notice.
And that's all the testosterone.
It cannot see this,
this weird Yin and Yang of the light.
And I noticed for myself though,
I calmed,
I used to be very much like that before I started taking testosterone.
And when I took the testosterone,
I like became a much calmer,
more focused,
more happy person than I did when I just had estrogen in my body.
That's fascinating.
Completely.
Where people,
you know,
use that roid rage,
which is all complete total bullshit.
Well,
it isn't.
It isn't.
I mean,
I've seen it.
I've seen it,
seen it.
Yeah.
I've seen it have,
without a doubt,
100% when men amount of Ted stomps.
Easy to do though,
if you're around men who want to be great big bodybuilders,
right?
There's only one way to do that.
You,
you have to Jack yourself up the way above the limits.
Right.
You know,
and you see,
I've seen people just completely lose their mind where they're like animals.
They like,
it's like being around a gorilla cause they're just juiced up to the gills.
They just an extraordinary amount of,
I'm sure like 50 million tons of whatever it is.
You don't think it's that much?
But I said,
yeah,
I know what you're saying.
Well that's,
if you see like that's the dirt.
It's not the dirty little secret.
It's the dirty,
obvious secret of bodybuilding,
right?
If you see one of those guys,
those enormous guys,
that doesn't make any sense.
The reason why it doesn't make any sense cause you know in your head you have
like a spectrum in your head.
Okay,
well if you're just,
if you're a man and you have to stoss drone,
you lift weights like a crazy feeling you can get about that big,
right?
Maybe that big.
If you've got super special genetics,
but what's this around the circle four or five times like you know,
you remember those things at the carnival you hit and it looks Dell goes up,
rings the bell.
These mother fuckers shot it to the moon.
Like they're so big.
That doesn't even make sense like this.
It's not possible to get there without drugs.
The Dysport literally cannot exist,
but don't they?
Like it doesn't make sense to me.
The whole,
the whole professional bodybuilding thing because people are tech nine taking
steroids.
They have to though for those sponsor companies,
like they get their money test.
You,
I don't know.
I mean,
you know,
they probably do,
but guys can get around it if they,
even if they do test,
if they test you,
it's ridiculous.
They'd be,
you know,
that's the reason why the NBA doesn't test for weed.
The NBA,
the NBA.
No,
they,
you know,
I think people have been popped for it somehow or another.
Um,
but very rarely.
And the reason is the,
the,
the players union knows that a giant percentage of those dudes around weed
smoking weed makes you sensitive to space and distances and stuff.
Like a lot of pool players smoke weed.
A lot of basketball players love to smoke weed and it helps your bright before
they applied.
Yeah.
I like it.
Narrowed it out.
I'd be like,
Oh yeah,
but you could though.
I bet you could if were to chai and black dude and you were good at basketball
and my last life.
Yeah.
They love to smoke weed and,
and it's awesome,
isn't it?
Bulletproof coffee.
Um,
when did you know that you like the concept of gender identity to someone who
doesn't struggle with it is,
um,
it's one of those things where you try to wrap your head around and he tried to
understand it,
but you'd never,
it's like,
why don't we say that a man and woman never really understand each other.
They just sort of get this thing where they accept that this is how you are and
this is,
but I never,
I'll never understand what it's like to want a baby in my body.
I never understand what it's like to have my period.
I'll never,
I'll never get it.
I'll never understand what it's like in any way.
And being a woman and then feeling like you're in the wrong sex.
What is that like and how did you,
when did you realize it?
It's imagine if you felt all of a sudden,
one day he started saying,
I feel like,
oh,
a girl.
It would freak you out.
Yeah.
Oh,
without a doubt.
Without a doubt.
I really most,
I mean I can just tell you what most of my life I felt that way,
but my parents did raise me like a boy.
Even though I was a little girl,
they completely raised me like a boy cause I wasn't very much of a Tomboy,
you know,
little tomboys or okay a girl who looks like a little boy and you know you're
tan and you dress like a little boy.
That's okay in this country,
nobody freaks out on that.
It's when you start reaching,
you know,
puberty and he started,
I started growing breasts and then I started,
you know,
getting my period.
That's when everything shifted.
It was totally okay my childhood.
But then people are like,
ah,
you need to start treating her like her.
Not like he,
my parents were completely freaked out because they always just,
it was like okay.
It was never an issue because I was just like a Tom boy.
And then when that happened,
I think that's when I'll like basically everything all hell broke loose,
you know,
it was it your folks that have the issue or the community that had the issue,
your neighborhood community,
their friends kept saying,
you've got to stop calling her.
He and the boy name it said,
girl.
You know what I mean?
Fuck.
Do they care what gender is such a freaky,
weird thing for people in our,
in the world.
Basically Amanda is this,
and a woman is that your,
your penis makes you a man and your vagina makes you a woman that's just black
and white.
For most people in the whole wide world.
That's just how it works.
And so basically that's not true because it's really how you feel inside your
outer presence is just the shell of your soul and your being really,
I mean,
it's,
to me it's that simple.
But of course people don't get it because people always take things at face
value.
They don't tend to get to know you or,
I mean,
I'm sitting right in front of you now.
Would you say that I am a woman?
No,
no,
thank you.
Have a beard.
Beard.
Yeah.
No,
you know,
basically a man.
Thank you.
I appreciate that compliment from him,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like the minute someone finds out that I have a pussy,
it's like,
no,
you're,
you're uh,
well,
you know what?
I think one day we're going to have a pill and you're just going to be able to
be a giraffe for a,
you know what I mean?
I really think that,
I think that they're going to be able to manipulate the human body to an extent
where it be unrecognizable.
I think we're going to be able to manipulate our genes to be,
look,
doctor Manhattan or something like,
totally.
I don't think it's,
I think the human frame is right now is something that we feel like is
completely outside of the realm of control,
but I think that's really temporary.
Just as temporary as we didn't think we were ever going to be able to
communicate with somebody in real time in Australia 150,000 years,
I don't know.
But today it's nothing,
and that's exactly what it's going to be like.
Whether it's 150 years from now or whatever,
you're,
your body's no longer going to define you.
You're going to be able to be whatever you want and people are going to be able
to switch back and forth.
Which from nearly Cox.
Yeah,
like this month I'm a girl,
I'm a guy,
I want to be already happening.
You know,
people are already doing the gender queer thing.
Are they where they're not saying I'm male or female.
And then there's like this new kind of thing called bay where they don't want to
identify as male or female and they're just,
they,
they're just day.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
That's,
I like to have a friend who's a day.
So every time I see her,
she used to be a herb and now she's a Va.
She always has to correct me because I'm always like saying her or she.
And so how do you,
what is the Pronoun for that?
It's very,
it's day.
Hmm.
I know it doesn't make any sense because it's not them.
So,
so you don't ever say he say she say they as as an individual as a day,
yeah.
Oh Wow.
Try it to Greg's need too much work that they need so much God damn attention.
Like all these labels and things that people are so obsessed with.
Right.
That's a real problem.
It's a real problem because now it's not LGBT.
It's,
you know,
now it's Q I a queer intersex and they,
and we have to add a t what I see.
Yeah,
I see.
What,
what is queer?
What's the difference?
Queer is more based on your,
I think your sexuality and how,
and and actually it kind of can encompass your gender.
So it's more of an all encompassing,
fluid fluidity with your gender and sexuality where you're not necessarily
saying I'm a he and I'm gay.
You might be a she and straight this day,
but tomorrow you want to be a man and gay
people are so specific.
I'm even getting all right.
Even me,
I'm just like,
I know I'm just a man.
Dude,
I know are so specific.
That's what I'm saying is getting a little bit,
okay,
here's the deal with my education.
That's why I always just sort of try to make it as easy as possible for being
home because I don't really go to that level at this point.
I want you first to understand that gender is complex,
but at the same time it's not.
It's really how you feel as a person and that people are understanding that,
you know,
I can be whoever I want to be and you and it's okay.
Does it matter what the world people are starting to be more open minded about
it?
They are.
And it's really important that people understand that it's going to evolve
whether you like it or not.
Yeah,
well gender's complex,
but for some people they don't want it to ever be complex because one of the
things that's admirable about a man as a man,
it doesn't worry what Sandro bottom man is a man who's just like fucking silent
Clint Eastwood and the movie's type doesn't give a fuck cause never thinking
about sucking Dicks,
just out there trying to shoot people,
you know,
like without a care in the world and keeps his heartbeat of steady 62 you know,
never really freaks out.
That's a,
that's a part of,
of being a man is being sure of your site and if you're unsure of your
sexuality,
you know you're a vulnerable animal.
But also I've learned to be very vulnerable.
And when,
you know,
I do a lot of public speaking and I talk about my childhood and my life and I
had a lot of stuff happened to me and you know,
I committed,
tried to commit suicide many times and I just hated my life and I was like total
nightmare.
And I get vulnerable when I speak and I have cried in public like that.
And actually it feels really good to go there sometimes because I know it
doesn't make me feel any less of a man.
I'm a very,
very confident,
very sure of myself,
man.
But to be vulnerable sometimes lets people understand your story a lot more and
lets them come into your life without smelling.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with being vulnerable.
That's a silly idea.
Especially for men.
Really.
I'm telling you,
especially for men,
a lot of us men really feel like we're not allowed to go there because it's not,
you're not a man if you let yourself be,
and that's totally bullshit.
Well,
it isn't.
It isn't.
And it isn't.
If you're being a bitch,
okay.
If you're crying for no fucking reason,
but that's the problem.
There's some people that cry for no reason.
Like to get a flat tire,
flat tire.
You're being a bitch,
right?
Dad and expressing love or talking about your childhood and your feet towards
moments or feelings.
Yeah.
But if you crying over your fighting your flat tire edge,
yeah,
I'm driving by it.
It does not of that though.
It's like it's important to differentiate right.
The difference between a person who is vulnerable because they're honest,
their emotions and passionate.
You know,
if you're passionate,
like did I cry easy man,
I cry,
I'll cry it a good commercial,
I'll cry.
And certain songs,
there's songs that hit me and I start crying.
Right.
You know,
movies,
I hate depressing movies because I cry like a little bitch,
you know?
Cause I'm,
I'm a very passionate person,
so I get locked into anything.
Like if I'm a involved in anyone's art,
whether it's a song or a movie or anything where you're,
you're,
you're painting this picture of torture,
of torment,
and I can relate to that character.
It's hard.
You know,
you feel it.
That's not [inaudible] go there.
And you know that those are actually the week.
I think you're right.
Yeah,
they're scared.
They're fake scared.
And if you don't understand what real fear is,
when you actually face it,
if you're constantly like hiding from like,
like your actual emotions and pretending you're not scared when you actually are
vulnerable,
then when you really are in danger,
you're not going to know what the fuck to do.
Right.
Because you don't know yourself,
right?
You don't know what you really are capable of.
You don't know who you really are,
so when the chips pile up,
you're going to just piss your pants and fall apart.
But men are taught that.
We're taught that from an early age man or not.
I really think so.
I don't know why though.
Why bitches for dads?
There's a lot of dudes out there that are just bitches.
They just fucked some chick,
get her pregnant,
and then they have a kid and that kid grows up with a bitch for a dad.
That's,
that's super common.
Yeah,
it is really cool.
I had a friend who had a fucking tremendous bitch for a dad.
His Dad would wind so much,
I would want to smack them in front of my friend.
I would go over it and then the guy would,
he was always so confused,
like,
I don't know what to do.
You forgot to list.
Stop.
Listen to your fucking dad.
All right.
That's the first thing that I do,
right?
Look at that guy.
If you didn't know that guy,
you would think that guy's a fucking idiot.
Right?
Okay.
He cries over nothing.
He's constantly whining.
He's always negative.
The guy's a bitch.
You need to get the fuck out of that toxic environment the first chance you get,
you know,
and that kind of shit.
Growing up,
this guy had no confidence about anything.
He was just,
he didn't know what he liked.
He didn't know what to do.
He had to ask everybody before he did anything.
It asks your opinion.
He didn't even know who the fuck you was.
Right?
He was never,
he was never shown that it was possible to know who the fuck you where he was
imitating this scared,
terrified thing in his house and it took until he separated from him.
It started having some milestones of his own graduating high school,
graduating college,
getting a degree,
following love,
having a relationship,
going into business that he started becoming a man,
but he had a break away from this bitch mold that he grew up in.
Well,
I think again,
parenting is also a very difficult situation,
right?
He was just thrown into parenting and there is no book real.
I mean there are books,
but you know,
still a lot of times people are just thrown into it.
There is no skill of how to raise my child or how to teach.
You learn that from your own parents and your own parents and you're,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's like this long.
I was lucky.
My Dad actually has very,
really hardcore,
he wasn't professional athlete,
he was very focused.
He was very much like that old school kind of guy,
but I think it actually helped me to become a really good man because I really
learned how to focus and be the person that I wanted
to be from that.
Sure,
of course it does.
I mean,
that's exactly what we're saying.
If you want to be a man,
you follow someone who was a man and he wanted to be a man.
Totally.
I mean it's,
it's a perfect example.
It's really difficult because a life you did not start out in a neutral point.
No one starts out at zero.
Right.
Some of US started at minus 30 other of us.
Some of US start out at plus 100 and sometimes the plus 100 people are fucked
because everything's too God damn easy,
right?
The minus 30 people and not telling me my,
I was probably like minus five minus 30 people that come from a dark background
a lot of times have this massive amount of expression inside of them because of
that.
And if they can sort it out,
it's almost like they have more horsepower,
you know,
their passion like,
like some of the great artists as far as music that tortured background,
tortured childhoods and you know,
it allows them to express themselves and this intense,
powerful way that someone who grew up in bel air isn't capable of doing exactly
like when you remember that Song Friday five remember that?
None of that shit.
The reason why people are so mad at that it was because they knew that this
bitch hadn't suffered at all.
Like you're not allowed to sing.
You know when you listened to like you listen to some old school blues and
Robert Johnson,
he listened at you like this motherfucker was hot.
They didn't have air conditioning.
They were sitting out there on the porch.
He was constantly and persecuted by white people.
He was women were trying to have his babies trying to get the fuck out of town
and stay on the road like you felt everything in that guy's voice.
That's the appeal of blues and the first close I live in New Orleans isn't that
fucked.
It's almost like you have to like have a shit childhood to become an interesting
person.
Well I didn't have a shit childhood.
I had a shit middle part of my life,
which actually did help me.
I always look at that part and I always remember being homeless,
doing prostitution on the streets,
like all of that really made me be the person as well.
What time did that start?
That was like later,
like in my mid twenties you know,
I was a professional model at one time as a woman and I traveled around Europe
and then I just couldn't do it anymore because I was doing it so much cocaine
and drinking and partying like mad.
They were like crazy mad and I just crashed.
Do you said though that when you were just getting your period and you were
young,
that's when people started giving you a hard time.
That wasn't a bad time in your life though.
Well yeah,
I was in high school still and so then,
you know,
I started having to deal with the high school thing and like,
you know a girl,
I'm becoming a wall,
a girl and I didn't and I'm attracted to girls,
you know,
and I was a lesbian,
I gas,
but I felt like a guy and this was,
you know,
30 or so more years ago and they didn't even talk about that kind of stuff when
I was going to high school.
So a lot of stuff was going on for me.
I started smoking weed.
Not that that's a bad thing,
but when you're not focused and you start doing those kinds of things and just
continues to escalate to hardcore drinky.
Then the cocaine and everything just escalating for
me and I got totally out of control for like since 16 to like maybe 28 I was
completely out of control when you were self medicating completely to it.
Those are the big difference right between that and enjoy it.
A little whiskey amongst friends.
Lately I'm totally cool with all of that.
Like I don't drank,
but for me it's just that I don't drink.
Not that I'm sober or do that,
I just don't rank it right.
It doesn't work for me.
It doesn't work for them.
There's nothing wrong with that either.
Right.
The that thing though about self medicating,
so common amongst kids that don't feel comfortable with who they are.
They just decided to just plunge themselves into a bottle or and to,
it's sad he'll bottle or because we also reinforce that and you'd society
saying,
yeah,
you're right.
You can't be gay.
It's completely not okay or it's weird that you feel like a girl or it's a weird
that you feel like a boy,
so we as a society reinforced those negative feelings constantly.
You're just feel shitty about yourself and you're like,
there is no out for me.
There is no out.
What am I going to do?
I cannot live as a woman anymore.
This is the next option is to kill myself.
That's why so many kids try to commit suicide now because they just feel no way
out of this situation.
You felt like you needed to add hormones to your life in order to complete your
vision of who you are.
I didn't even know I could do that.
I have my change over 21 years ago when there was no internet really,
there was no doctors.
Ma.
I was the first trans man doctor in Los Angeles.
He never even met a guy like me before.
Same with my top,
my chest surgery,
all of that.
These guys were like,
oh,
okay,
but you're basically going to be our Guinea pig.
I mean,
it didn't even exist,
but I knew I needed to change.
And so I was willing to take that always in the back of my head is if it didn't
work,
I'm just going to kill myself.
I mean,
really think about how crazy that is.
That was always my option.
I'm going to try this.
If it doesn't work,
I'm just going to kill myself because that's how life threatening it was.
It was like I had to do it.
It was life or death for me.
And this was something that built up over time or was this totally,
yeah.
So you had reached a point when you were in your 20s when you were out of
control and partying and drinking.
You were trying to avoid yourself play.
And then once you finally face yourself,
you're like,
okay,
I either have to do something about this or let's see what's done or I'm done,
I'm done.
I can't continue to have people confront me as a woman.
You know,
she and I was like,
ha,
I was like a dyke,
you know,
like,
short hair and then people,
you know,
say Shit,
throw stuff at me on the street.
Yeah.
DYC We're going to kick your ass.
Like people used to follow me and try to fight.
I was a total fight or date,
but you know,
like that was my life and it was like,
you get tired of that.
You get really tired of constantly having to fight people's negativity towards
you constantly and you're like,
I don't want to be this way anymore.
Was it men that would,
would Matt,
aggressive man,
man or woman?
Never women always men following me,
throwing shit at me,
trying to fight me.
Like,
you know,
jumping me three or four guys jumping me,
like to say,
I don't know where it did.
Where was this at?
La,
West Hollywood,
those kinds of things like
gay bashing basically.
I didn't know that women face it that often.
Oh totally.
Especially when you look like a little boy,
but they can tell you're a girl.
You know what I mean?
It was like,
yeah,
it was a nightmare for me.
I was like,
I'm really lucky to be where I am today because really I should be dead,
so I really should be dead and so many aspects of my life I should just not be
here.
So you went to a doctor and you had this idea in your head like,
look,
there's gotta be a way.
Yeah,
totally.
I had seen a documentary with a woman who changed to a man.
It was from Europe or something.
And I'm like,
how come nobody told me this is possible?
Like nobody even therapists or psychologist or psychiatrist.
When I went to tell her I psychiatrist,
I feel like a man and she was like,
well,
you're just a very male identified female.
But the fuck is that.
I feel like a man.
She didn't even have the lingo to like come back at me and like,
you know what Buck,
you can have a sex change.
Like never did anybody say that to me.
So how do you find,
like if someone doesn't gender identify with being a male and there,
you know what,
what,
what do you do?
Say if you're a man and you want to become a woman around when you want to
become a man,
what's the steps?
You fucking Google it right now.
Then I had to go to a bookstore and find this old book and find a doctor in the
back that was like for transgender,
for women,
for men becoming women.
They didn't even have anything for guys like me.
And I found this book.
I mean,
I was like determined to figure out how to do this.
And I called this doctor and Hollywood here and he's like,
well,
I never worked with a woman who wants to become a man,
but why don't you come in?
And he saved my life and he's like,
all you'll be my Guinea pig.
We'll figure out.
That's fascinating that there were so many women that came women from men,
but that became men who were women.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a new movement now.
There's a lot more happening.
But uh,
did you kickstart it?
Nah,
it's been happening.
But I think I did kind of take a little credit that,
um,
so you went to this doctor and then,
so he says you're going to be his Guinea pig.
Yup.
And how does he starts to say he starts giving me very small doses of
testosterone.
Very,
you would laugh like teeny weeny.
Right?
And then he just fought,
checks me out,
make sure everything's gold.
Within six months he has me up to one CC of testosterone,
teaches me how to inject it myself and sees a whole cc cc and a week every two
weeks.
Jesus Christ.
That's a lot.
You think so?
Yeah.
And then we just,
six months later he's like,
I want to teach you how to do it yourself so that you can go on with your life.
And you know what an amazing man relay.
It was amazing.
He taught me and then I went on and it was like,
I was like reborn.
I was reborn.
It like literally like physically and mentally changed my life.
Do you get testosterone in Mexico?
Yes.
No.
Do you worry that it might be bullshit?
No,
no.
It's fucking oil.
Fuck no dude,
it's real.
I used to sustain on right now so you like cause Mexican pharmaceutical drugs.
You can basically get whatever the fuck you want to I have or you
want.
That's kind of cool.
Happy about the way Mexico like the,
the,
the drug wars chaos and it's,
it's really sad.
You see all the violence over there and it's very depressing.
However,
there's a certain amount of freedom that comes to having a shit government
fairly in control of its populous.
They're getting their shit together dude.
But he was call the pharmacy and then they deliver it to your house for free.
They deliver it
like,
you know,
self medicate the fuck you want.
21 years into it.
I completely know what I'm doing now.
It's not the night.
That's fascinating.
And I inject myself and my life just started to change and then I decided I
needed to get my breasts removed even though they weren't big.
I needed to have a male chest.
I mean that was always my ultimate thing is to be able to take my shirt off.
I mean,
that's like such a guy thing.
Hung around with your shirt off and I found a doctor who had never worked with a
guy like me and he did it.
Yeah.
I thought that was fascinating about Chaz Bono is that there was photographs of
Chaz walking on the beach after she became Chaz and he has these big scars under
his breasts,
but because of the fact that now he identifies as a man in regular publications,
they're showing him topless and I'm like,
good.
That was really interesting because you really can't have a problem with it.
But if he was still a woman before the sex change,
then it would be a real issue.
The same nipple,
I know it.
You're right on to it shows you how fucking stupid dude.
Totally chest.
Well,
it's also,
the Internet has really flipped the script on what we're used to seeing,
what we can see,
what we can accept.
I had never seen a man that had become a woman until you,
so on my message board,
I have a message board filled with freaks and savage and they fucking,
they knew about you back in the nine horse.
My,
my website's been around since [inaudible] 98.
I mean,
I don't know when,
uh,
I was introduced to you on the website years and years ago,
but that you are a,
just a,
like a new piece in this new vision of the world.
You know,
there's new thing that exists that didn't exist with father knows best was on
the air and you know,
the twilight zone was shocking.
You know what I mean?
It's everything now is,
there's the,
the amount of information is so much larger this,
the scope of the canvas,
the size of the canvas of reality is so much larger and you're a part of that.
You're,
you're a part of that.
I think so.
It will be,
because really what it comes down to is my genitals.
And when I went to the world and said,
you know what,
I don't need to have a penis to be a man.
I just went to the world and said,
fuck you,
I did well,
this is a really interesting photo of you.
That's all my message board on this.
There's a thread that someone put up about this,
uh,
particular conversation and it's you like lounging back completely naked,
smoking a cigar and it's like for half your body,
it's like the manliest shit
possible is yoked up dude smoking a cigar with a beard covering tattoos and
there's a vagina.
It's like,
right.
whoa.
Yeah.
The,
your,
your identity,
you know,
the,
the of,
you know,
your idea of what a man is like is immediately challenged and it's always like,
how do you feel about this?
Cause what,
what exactly you're seeing here and what is this?
What,
what bothers you?
Does it,
is this change your view of reality?
You know,
it's awesome.
Mean I really feel honored to be able to do that to the world and it's an honor
and a wide shot to really push the thought of what,
what is this?
What is male and female and gay and straight?
What is,
what is,
what are you and what are the problems?
Why,
why do they exist?
Do they exist because someone is threatening you?
Do they exist because you're threatened by it?
What exactly is the issue?
What is your cause now you have to look at yourself because you before looked at
me like a man and all of a sudden you'll see my vagina and you're like,
ah,
holy.
And mostly it's males that do that because you know,
men are pretty,
uh,
pretty attached to their penis.
I mean,
you know that.
Understandably so.
But that,
that's just so now I'm saying to you,
you don't have to have that to be a man.
It's really challenging your own identity in a way.
Yeah.
It gets,
it gets slippery.
But it's,
so though the slippery thing is not even that,
oh,
that's a man too.
It's like what,
what is the controversy like?
Not that he's unusual,
not that he's unique,
but what bothers people?
What gets them angry?
What does
angry mass gets so much to kill me.
I have to like have security sometimes when I go speak because people all,
yeah,
they're telling me they're gonna kill me if I show up.
What kind of people can you imagine?
What kind of people?
For example,
Yale University,
they were going to find,
they were saying,
if you show up here,
we will kill you.
Who said that?
Students.
Students and alumni.
And of course I had to report it.
I mean I,
I didn't want to be like that bitch.
Right.
I was like,
bring it on and then you know,
people are like,
you better chill out dude.
You don't know,
they might be there.
So I had to report it to the people who brought me in and uh,
they had 24 hour security the whole time I was there.
We always have to be worried about the one fucking wing.
You never know.
That's the broad spectrum.
But I deal with that all the time.
I don't deal with it as much as I used to.
I have to tell you that people have become much more understanding and much more
supportive.
My fan base has grown tremendously in the last,
I would say five years.
Just crazy.
What do you attribute that to?
A,
I think listening to me and seeing that I'm just like a normal guy.
It's not really a big deal and telling you how amazing my life is and then I'm a
positive person and that all I want really is for people to be able to be
themselves,
whatever that means.
Do you think that it reflects a change in society as a whole?
Uh,
clearly it has to be.
I mean,
people are opening up their minds and understanding that,
yeah,
you know it,
this person has happy,
so why am I angry about it?
Right.
I face it.
The progressive ideas are way more mainstream than they've ever been in way
more.
And I think it's because of the Internet,
because the open dialogue,
the Internet presents like you realize like you know,
there's a lot of these people,
they don't,
they're not really much different than you or I this,
they're,
they're just like you or I,
they're not evil.
There's nothing wrong with them.
They're just there as a different thing.
There this you're that,
you know,
they liked this kind of music.
You think it sucks,
but you liked that kind of music and then,
but there's so many commonalities that we,
eh,
sort of inform each other of because the internet,
you kind of go,
well wait a minute,
what's our real problem here?
Like is it sexuality,
is it gender identification or we just distracting ourselves with this nonsense.
Well that's a very specific kind of person now because as you know,
I mean the Internet is full of trolls for days and those ones really are the
ones who react and do huge neck and continue to make it very negative on the
Internet.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
So of course we have the people like you and your fans and the people are
willing to listen and,
and talk about these kinds of things.
But then we have the other side that's so incredibly hateful and never wants
this kind of thing to be accepted in the world.
Yeah.
The trolls issue is a fascinating one because really all it is is unhappy
people.
It's a huge sea of unhappy people saying shitty mean things.
Oh,
they're crazy.
They're crazy.
Those are the ones that say,
I'm going to kill you.
You of course you have no life.
Well,
they're sitting at home molten and again,
most of them don't mean a word they're saying,
oh no,
I always say that.
Totally.
But there's a few that might,
there's a few broken ones telling Ya.
You know,
and you,
you have to protect yourself in those situations.
You have winglets after you,
you must have a friendly guy,
easy to get along with,
but you are,
but so am I.
It's like a giant vagina.
They don't even know what I have.
I might have been faking the funk the whole time.
Who knows?
Um,
I think that the angry thing is also,
um,
because of the lack of real interaction because of the fact they were able to do
it over the Internet.
There's no,
there's no like social repercussions.
When you look at someone,
you say something mean like you have to be a psychopath.
If someone's never done anything to you and you look at them,
you say something mean and you see them react and you see,
you see it hurt their feelings.
It doesn't bother you,
you,
you're broken person,
you're associated with it.
There's something wrong with you,
but when you do it on the Internet it's like you can just like,
oh just say something shitty and cause you're removed from us.
You're completely removed from it.
The lack of,
but I think that this is temporary.
I really think this is like this crazy chaos before the age of enlightenment.
I'm and I'm,
and I'm a big believer in progress and I'm a big believer in utopia,
utopia and ideas and to the point where it's unrealistic,
like I have some pretty unrealistic views of the possibilities of humanity that
those are important for use to
have because I'm very much the same way.
I believe that if we have,
I am a believer of energies.
First off,
if I give off positive energy,
I always get positive energy back.
I agree.
I think that's huge.
If you give,
if I came into this room right now with the attitude that was not like cool and
I was just sitting here waiting for you to talk shit to me,
me and you are going to have not as good as a situation going on between us.
I don't think right now I think it would be my,
but because I'm coming in with that energy,
that negative,
go ahead and say it to me dude energy,
right?
Which a lot of people in my situation tend to have because they don't understand
that you have to under people do not understand us.
And when I come,
when I come to explain to you the situation,
I have to understand that you don't get it and you already have a preconceived
notion about it and you're already judging me and that's okay.
It's because you don't get it.
So I have to come to it with an understanding of that and understanding that I
need to now teach you and the best way to teach somebody is to be happy about it
and to let you have your feelings and then hopefully I can win you over with the
fact that I'm just a happy dude and it's not right.
And you can say things to me.
It doesn't hurt me because it's you don't understand.
Right.
That's fine.
You're not going to change who you are with their words,
but if I'm angry at you and you're calling me like a freak or do,
that's totally freaky and weird.
No,
I understand that.
You think it's freaking weird cause it Kinda is freaky and weird,
right?
I totally get it.
I'm not,
I'm not totally out of bounds with that.
I completely understand that the man with a pussy is kind of weird and funny.
Well you know the anger thing where people want to kill you and then the troll
thing,
whether they're hating and I think all that is just misused potential.
That's what I think.
I think the human mind is incredibly complex.
But it doesn't come with an instruction manual.
It doesn't come with you.
Imagine if the human body was a vehicle that you had to learn how to use and how
long you'd have to go to school for.
They would give you a license to operate a human body.
I mean Jesus Christ,
if you were an an an inferior being,
if you were something that existed in thought only,
and the only way to manifest yourself in the real world was get a license to use
a body.
You know,
if the,
the human body was just like,
like a car,
right?
You,
you would,
she's as Christ.
You'd have to learn a lot of shit.
I have to learn.
You'd have to like,
well we have to find out how you're going to interact with the other humans,
right?
So you got to understand cause and effect.
You got to understand action reaction.
You got to understand the powerful benefits of positive energy.
You got to understand love.
You've got to understand insecurity,
right?
You got to understand jealousy.
You got to understand all these waters that need to be navigated before we let
you in the stream of humanity.
Right?
And we don't,
we just fucking take these all this potential and just go get out of the fucking
house and we push them out into the river.
And I think that's why a lot of those self help books are
people who teach those way of thinking are so huge.
Because I think people want to learn to be like that really?
And the underlying part of it,
people want to learn how to be calm and happy.
And how does that person have that energy?
Yeah,
I do.
I get that.
Um,
it's turned to be a big benefit of this podcast.
That's one of the big benefits that people always cite is that they have a
chance to see a perspective other than the one they've been told is the one
that's supposed to follow.
Right?
And then all of a sudden they're like,
oh yeah,
like,
oh,
I don't have to be a dick.
Oh,
I can like take personal responsibility.
I can be nice to people.
I can look at this as some sort of a weird temporary situation.
And the best case scenario is you have as many friends and loved ones and you
share great moments during this time period that you're conscious
and that's a huge thing that you're doing really because you're changing the way
you're changing that way and that way people think.
And then those people go to other people and then they say the same thing.
So you're sorta like moving that positive energy along that totally line line of
people
and it's,
yeah,
and it's only positive possible for me because I've got those ideas and that
vibe and those,
those good thoughts from other people online.
Exactly.
And it spreads and you just got to learn what to focus on and what not to.
And if you,
if I wanted to go online and just pay attention to all the people who are
trolling,
I'd fucking run my head through a wall.
I would be,
if I only concentrated on them exactly everywhere.
If you have any sort of an internet presence whatsoever or say anything
controversial,
which I have both,
you're going to have a massive amount of people that want to just push your
buttons and just,
just pet potential.
They're just potential that is misused almost universally because there's some
people that disagree with me on a bunch of different ideas and there's tuts
totally cool.
And I mean,
and,
and I expect it,
of course,
and it's one of the things that I always make sure that the point that in most
situations there's not a right or wrong in most situations there's,
you think this,
and I may agree with you,
but I might disagree with you and neither one of us is right,
right.
It's just this is my perspective and this is your perspective.
And when people start approaching things like that,
then you can kind of learn from other people's points of view,
right?
And you go,
oh,
I see why he thinks it sucks because of this.
Or I see why he loves that because of that.
But the real problem is,
is when people want you to feel how they feel,
right?
They feel like shit.
They're hurting,
they,
they're hateful,
they're there,
they're just a mess.
And they just want to just throw up shit all over you and just turn your life.
And the same kind of shit that they have.
No,
I totally get that.
And I get a lot of those haters toward,
they turn my words around and they say,
Buck said this about trans women should do this call.
Never said that.
Read the interview.
But I had to learn how to block them because I did it.
I'll be honest,
I did take it personally at one time.
I totally like,
Ooh.
And then I was like,
okay,
well,
wait a minute.
It's not me.
It's not my agenda.
It's their agenda.
It's not about what I do.
And so then I just had to learn to remove
myself from their situation.
I would say that people like that,
or like snake venom,
you get a little bit of in your system and then you get immune and then when the
snake bites so you don't die right.
You know,
you go,
oh,
I know what you're doing.
Exactly.
Snake poison.
He totally get it.
It's really just like that.
And it's both on the,
the side of the assholes,
but also on the side of the progressive's.
I see progressive's going after each other with snake venom,
you know,
accusing each other of crazy cause like you said before,
it's that you're at,
you want to put your agenda on someone else and they have to,
if they don't get it and if they are not onboard with you,
then they're the bad person.
I don't understand people who don't understand what you just said.
You have an opinion about it and I have an opinion about it and it's totally
cool.
I respect your opinion and you respect my opinion and then why can't we just
leave it at that?
There's a lot of people that use the vehicle of discourse to try to hurt other
people's opinions,
hurt other people's feelings and to score points.
They'll like shit on people to score for themselves.
And I see it a lot and I'm not talking about someone making fun or using humor
or like a Kanye west Jimmy Kimmel type situation,
which is totally warranted.
And I think Jimmy Kimmel's defense,
he's doing Kanye west of favor.
Like Kanye West needs to see how fucking ridiculous he looks.
Yeah.
Because he's not being cool about it.
He's,
he was being completely uncool and that interview and even less cool afterwards,
it reaffirmed why Jimmy Kimmel should have done exactly.
So I'm not talking about that,
but I get so disturbed when I go online and people who are,
whether they're feminists or whether they're skeptics,
are atheists attacking each other,
attacking people in the community,
like coming out with reasons why this person's a rapist because he had sex with
someone when they were drunk and everyone who does,
that's a rapist.
And they're also taking this weird moral high ground.
When they do that,
they're getting Brownie points,
right?
Getting Social Brownie points while they're doing it right.
And you see it,
it's,
it's transparent and disgusting and it works.
It works.
It totally works.
You see it,
you see them like people praising them.
Thank you so much for saying it's exactly why they do a little cheesy.
Myers is,
you know this whole thing with Michael Shermer?
No,
it's fascinating.
Shit.
He's accusing this guys is very famous skeptic.
Michael Shermer of not even rape.
The woman's saying that Michael Shermer put her in a position where she could
not have consent,
she could not consent.
And what was very ambiguous,
the,
the assumption is she was drunk because he uses as corroborating evidence
another woman's tale where she met him at a party and he made sure her glass was
always full and she got drunker than she normally does and she's literally using
this to corroborate what he said.
Meaning that he got her drunk,
like completely removing herself from any personal responsibility for actually
drinking and being an adult and getting drunk and somehow or another like
corroborating the,
the story of the other person that he got her into a position where she couldn't
consent.
It's weird sort of,
there's this weird sort of feminist skeptic language they use like these
privilege a lot.
Yeah.
That's the new,
the new language.
Dead privileges.
A weird one.
Right.
Privileges away.
When I had to really learn that,
oh,
I get checked on that all the time,
dude.
I'm a now a privileged white man.
You get checked on that.
All the male privilege,
white privilege,
white get checked on and they use it to diffuse your argument.
Oh yes.
They didn't use it to diffuse your viewpoint.
They use it to,
and it's,
it's this weird fucking,
so when they sang it,
he has a male white privilege and that,
that discounts the fact.
So she doesn't have to take any responsibility whatsoever.
Yeah,
I'm gonna.
I have to tell you that I disagree with that.
Well everyone who you have now,
people are going to talk shit about me for days on the Internet and I don't
really fucking care because the situation is this.
It takes two fucking people.
Yeah,
it does.
The,
so what they've taken,
they've taken a hard stance.
The other way saying that everyone who has sex with anyone who's drunk is raping
them and including women who have sex with drunk men.
If you have sex with a drug saying the man,
you're raping the man.
No Man would ever admit that though,
Ben,
we're happy to get rich.
It's so preposterous and it's so gross.
It's a bunch of social retards.
That's the reality.
The reality is it's social retires and they're,
first of all,
you're ignoring the broad spectrum of alcoholic and Ebda.
Exactly.
There's tipsy and then there's fucking unconscious conscious that's rape.
Just before she wasn't.
That's great.
Three quarters before unconscious athlete unconscious pretty much raped.
I mean it gets,
it gets less raping as you get more sober,
but the reality of,
you know,
I'm not laughing about rape,
I just want everybody to know that it is true.
I mean,
I think the genius of the Feminine Agenda In this respect,
it's almost like a,
it's almost a side effect and that genius is,
it forces the conversation because it is important.
It is important.
And people who get people fucked up and do things to their body,
fucking assholes.
They're pieces of shit.
Totally.
Whether it's a man or whether it's a woman care.
Yes,
and I think that there's,
there's a good in that that this argument,
yes.
Discussed,
but I don't buy the delivery man.
I don't buy that Pz Myers guy.
I think he's a creeper and I think what the way he released that information
without,
first of all,
he's supposed to be a skeptic and the word skeptic,
if you're a skeptic,
you understand that the worst piece of evidence that you can possibly receive,
right?
It's a personal experience.
Someone telling you what happened,
right.
You don't know what they're saying.
You don't know how much of what they're saying.
It's not only that,
he didn't even get it secondhand,
you didn't get it from the person.
He got it second hand.
Wow.
You got it from another person who told him.
So it's nonsense.
Now it's getting totally blown out.
Yeah.
Oh,
totally blown out.
Yeah,
totally blown.
This is why I can prove he's a creeper.
Jamie,
pull this up.
Pull up.
Pz Myers isn't a feminist.
There's this video of him at this conference making all these jokes with this
woman saying that she's going to,
she would have to have sex with him if she got these,
this card game wrong.
She got the wrong card.
It's so gross and so transparent that I kind of love when you find a jewel like
this because you get to see,
well,
oh,
this is a social retard.
This is a guy that's socked with women his whole lives and now he's in this
position of power being a professor.
So he decides that he's a male feminist and so yes he is and so he bathes in the
warm milk of the adulation of all the people that are super progressive that go
along with them.
Yet he stifles dissent in a very radical way in his forums.
If you disagree,
even if you disagree in a very polite and civil way.
With him,
outing is Michael Shermer guys,
I suppose it rapist for having sex with an intoxicated woman.
Even if you disagree in a civil way,
he bands you from the forum and he's an idiot because now he's not open for
discussion and it's all about him and his idea.
Massive censorship.
So wait,
so he outdid the guy who raped the girl.
Well,
he outdid the guy who he says he was told had sex with a woman who could not
consent.
No one ever says rape,
but he uses the word rape liberally after that.
And it's,
it's a weird thing.
He doesn't say the guys are rapist,
but in other posts they talk about rape and that is rape and having sex with
someone who's intoxicated is rape,
but that the,
the broad black,
the black and white scale of that is so ridiculous.
But it's also why are you responsible when you drive,
but you're not responsible when you fuck.
No.
That's a great point,
man.
You don't really know that you're too drunk to fuck.
Right.
You don't get yourself in that position.
And I'm not saying rape is okay.
Again,
I need to,
I need to say that.
But what is wrong,
Ashley?
A lot of times women put themselves in these ways,
and I'm not saying they should be raped,
but really the world is fucked up.
You know?
Getting drunk and a situation that could turn bad is not a smart choice.
Yeah,
but I don't think you should ever blame the woman for 19 align.
I don't even like to think that way because they have to be.
Have to.
Yes.
I'm telling you.
I'm telling you,
I can say that because I used to be a woman.
You can not put yourself in that situation.
I'm totally on the same page with you.
However,
I don't think that it's not okay to rape.
So I know it's a double.
I'm kind of saying something really kind of roundabout,
but really be conscious of these things.
Yes.
Don't put yourself in an environment.
It's almost unrelated to this story.
This guy,
there's no excuse.
If he did fuck,
get someone fucked up and do something to their body.
There's no excuse for that.
Right?
Right.
Whether or not this woman shouldn't have been there,
but she should have known better.
It doesn't matter,
but we don't know what he don't know what happened.
Exactly what happened to call yourself a skeptic.
Yes.
And to put,
that's not a skeptic about what they're doing.
What they're doing is getting social brownie points.
They are bathing and the warm glow of the adulation of their followers.
That's the things.
You can't say anything anymore without people taking it and saying you're saying
one thing.
Did you find that video play?
Please listen to this.
This is fascinating.
Pulled it up so we can see it doing your belly dance while this is,
this is the guy,
this is the guy with the beard who apparently is a very brilliant man and I'm
professor of biology and she made a lot university clothes off.
What's Nice,
she made me
see my clothes off.
Can you just let it?
Yeah,
I,
this is where this,
this video,
uh,
some guys annoyed at him
for all these different things.
We lie,
we lie.
We always lie to you.
So get off my stage.
I got work to do.
So He's,
and around here,
everything's cool.
You know,
just being silly with someone.
Now this is him dealing with the other woman.
Some cards.
Okay.
You write there purple shirt.
Yes,
you'll do.
So he does not know very clearly.
Does not know her pulling her out of the audience.
I Dunno what that says.
We can't see it because there were a thing.
So is it turns on the charm.
Okay.
Of course there could also be higher stakes.
We could say,
you know,
for instance,
if I win this hand,
I get to kill any chew
they're playing,
they're playing cards here possibly.
Uh,
another thing is,
you know,
if you win the hand,
they know I would have to submit and have sex with you.
Wow.
Okay.
He's just joking around I guess.
But it's very awkward.
You have to submit and have sex with you.
Imagine if that was your wife.
You win.
Okay.
Look at it.
I will give you my hotel room number.
Write down what we'll do the sex thing later anyway.
Wow.
Okay.
The brush off.
Well,
it says go back to your seat.
No,
take the cards with you.
I'm good.
I gotta call you back for the sex part later.
So hang on.
Okay.
You hear that buddy
in the feminist movement.
Okay,
let's just,
you don't need to play the rest of it,
but that
guy needs to shut the fuck up.
I'm like,
my brain is kind of getting it from what I,
what my suspicions were.
My suspicions were social retard.
Right.
And that is,
that's the,
those are the words of a social retard.
Yeah.
That's an awkward person.
Tries to make a joke about having sex with a woman.
Yeah.
I am a feminist.
Yes,
exactly.
If that was your wife or girlfriend and he did that,
you would be horrified anyways.
I don't care if it was my wife or a girlfriend.
He,
he,
he's not a feminist.
Yeah.
You don't talk like that as a feminist.
You first off,
that's just really inappropriate behavior.
He's a hypocrite.
Oh,
clearly.
And,
but,
but what I was saying before was that even people in the progressive movement do
Shitty,
douchey things like that.
Like this guy with this Michael Sherman thing,
right?
It's this,
it's that it all comes from the same place.
It doesn't come from a place of love.
It doesn't come from a place of peace.
No.
Even in reaching out to try to supposedly elevate those who are in trouble or
who are depressed or who are or repressed or who are,
who were shit on by society.
You are doing
it to prop yourself up a and to hurt someone else,
isn't it?
You're not doing it in a loving way.
That's an agenda.
Clearly an agenda.
And he found his,
found his people that he could totally work as agenda to.
Exactly which is that feminist fucking dangerous.
And that's just it.
Just like religion.
Yeah.
We were talking about earlier today,
it's the same thing.
It's coming from a place of fear.
It's coming from a place of control.
It's the same goddamn thing.
And the control,
it's super obvious when you see the fucking suppression of free speech that he
puts on his own blogs.
The fact that on his own blogs,
he sensors,
anybody that disagrees,
even if they disagree,
sits on a piece of shit.
Like he doesn't even know what he's doing.
And that's the thing is with communities,
a lot of times they censor our speech and they tell us,
we can't say,
and I'm using myself as an example here.
I'm not allowed to say certain things because they don't reflect our community
pro,
but I'm like,
but I'm a person first and it is the way I believe.
And I think it is important for me to speak my mind about certain things.
We all can't think the same way.
Like we talked about earlier.
We all have different ways we think things should be or things.
And it's only from my own personal experience,
but within my specific community,
I'm not allowed to say certain words or react to certain things.
I'm not like who?
Why?
Well,
I think for a lot of folks that do feel marginalized or have been marginalized,
like Dave fucking,
they've hit that the guy from network are mad as hell and I'm not going to take
me anymore.
Right?
So like these are the parameters.
This is what we'll accept.
This is what we want except in,
in,
in that way.
I understand that.
I do,
but I'm telling you right now,
I wouldn't be where I am right now.
If I had that anger,
I wouldn't be get in the door,
didn't get in the doors.
People wouldn't want to listen to me because I was Morocco and I really have to
tell you a lot of the communities are really angry and they alienate people like
myself who want to further our acceptance in the world.
I have obviously I want to but because I don't use the same way driving angry
force,
then I'm the bad person.
I'm actually not for that and I don't believe in that.
I believe,
like I said earlier,
really getting people to understand you have to educate the people who don't
understand us and isn't it funny that like when we were talking about earlier
like weird acronyms that people you,
categories that are very specific and then language like privileged that gets
used almost as like,
you know like,
like you let them know you're speaking the lingo feasible.
Noam Chomsky actually addressed this because he's a linguist and he was talking
about how they're sort of pretending like,
like a lot of a radical progressive's pretending that this is almost scientific
because they hear quantum theorists talk and this is like really strange if
theory will language that no one really understands.
So they sort of use the same kind of jargon in regards to psychology and
sociology and in regards to like progressive.
Exactly.
And so they're not trying to be understood.
They're trying to be outside of the realm of understanding so that you can't
question them,
that you aren't going to question them,
but they don't in their mind you can't,
you don't even get it.
It's Lbtq team that's totally out of,
you're an Ari and I don't use it.
So like I don't know if you know what CIS gender it is.
Know what does that mean?
I've heard that.
I don't know what basically I biological per like you are born in the body that
you have chosen to be in what assistant for?
So sis,
you have to look it up on the Internet.
I don't use it.
And I'll tell you why.
Gender,
C I s yeah,
so I don't use it and I don't,
it's fine.
I use it.
I use it because I want to educate.
Now I have to educate you on cis gendered and when I just used the word
biological,
you get biological,
do you not?
Yes,
that's better.
That's better.
CISGENDER and Wikipedia.
According to Wikipedia,
oftens of really abbreviated to simply sis described related types of gender
identity where an individual self perception of their gender matches the sex
they were assigned at birth.
So meaning biological,
biological,
yeah,
but they felt a need and I'm not being rude or disrespectful,
but it they felt a need to make their own word because you have,
you as a biological person or the straight world has made have made words for
us.
So it's sorta like we now have our own word for you.
So I'm like that's cool.
Go right ahead.
But that's not,
you know,
for me,
I need to educate you and if I keep getting watered down,
you lose,
you lose it,
you lose it and you're not really getting it.
Do you know about the case where there was a,
a a man who became a female and then started MMA fighting sort of my friend.
She's your friend,
of course.
What do you think about that situation?
What do you think about the,
uh,
first of all,
the fact that she didn't tell people that she used to be a man,
right.
Mechanic and fought a bunch of women.
And I get it.
I got it.
And then now that she wants to compete as a woman,
well,
okay,
I,
she's a woman.
To me,
She completely changed.
He identifies as a woman.
Again,
we're going to come back to what makes you a man and a woman right now with
fighting,
with fighting.
I,
it's not my profession and it's not my thing.
I don't,
but she wrote me,
so can I show you what she wrote me?
Sure.
And then I want you to read it.
That you can see what she said.
Because of course I knew you were going to bring this up.
And I think it's very important that you get it from her.
Because for me,
I can't speak for her because she's a trans woman.
I'm a trans man.
But you can't speak for her because it's not.
And also it's not me.
And also I'm not,
I'm not versed enough in that world of,
of this,
of that sport.
So I can't tell you what the rules,
but if you were just going to ask me generally what I feel about it,
I do feel that she has a woman and I do feel that she has the right to fight as
a woman.
It's like saying that I can't use the men's restroom because I'm not really a
man.
It is a general kind of way.
Again.
Well why don't you read what you need first to see this?
Cause I think it is super important that um,
I think it's a completely valid argument.
110% don't get wrong,
but I,
oh,
I don't have any service in here.
What a bummer.
[inaudible] t and t?
No,
I have t mall because I have one.
It was unlocked phones.
Can you step outside that door?
You can.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We have it.
Yeah.
Jamie,
can you give them passwords?
Nope.
Let me since while you're looking for,
here's two issues with it.
One that I have is the male frame.
The mechanics of the male frightened it is different.
It's different.
Like if you are a person who has large man hands and man's shoulders,
that doesn't go away.
If you take estrogen and the mechanics of the male frame or a significant
advantage,
there's also a significant advantage in reaction speed that men enjoy 10% it's a
massive amounts that's across the board pretty much when athletes is a massive
reaction time difference between men and females.
There's also learning the skills as a man being up to 30 years of being a man
and then becoming a woman.
These are all completely unfair advantages that a man would have entering into
female combat sports.
Now,
every man is the same time.
I'm not saying that we will get into that,
but here's the big one.
The big one is she didn't say that she used to be a man.
She never told anyone?
No,
not until it came out.
And then when it came out,
the last fight was sanctioned as her being a trans woman.
But the fights before that,
her opponents,
I've spoken to them,
they were furious.
They were upset and they were told that they were bigots by people online.
They were attacked.
This one girl who emailed me and thanked me,
she was telling me that she was getting attacked left and right by so called
progressive's because they were calling her a bigot because a trans woman that
she didn't know.
It used to be a man fodder and she was pissed off about it because the kind of
rag daalder well,
I mean there's so much more involved in it,
so you know that right.
It can't,
it's not black and white like anything on talking it.
Nothing is black and white.
It's just not.
It's not.
And I shouldn't say the guy,
should she ragdolled her,
she beat the shit out of them.
Like a guy would be the shit out of women.
It's hard to watch because if you watch the physical advantages that she has
over these women,
I she's not that good.
I know what,
when I look at someone who's good technically profession,
I totally,
I understand what I'm seeing as someone ragdoll people.
I'm seeing her smashed these girls and then I think it's because of her frame
app.
Look at my hands,
see the size of my hands.
No matter how many female hormones I took,
I would still have them look at my hands.
Exactly.
Hands,
gas of advantage.
There's a massive advantage in the shape of the hips.
There's a massive advantage and the width of the shoulders,
there's size of the psychological women that are her side.
You're right.
There are,
there are a few,
but it's still not exactly the same.
This to the mechanical advantages of the mailbox is still exist if you have a
man and a woman and that the same way in those same sort of muscularity,
there's still a difference in the frame.
This is difference in the shape of the hips.
There's a difference.
The
reaction time frame is still female.
Yeah,
I totally understand that.
But that said,
I think,
I think you have to read what she said because again,
I think it's important.
There are variables though,
and there's,
there's Serena Williams who's a female totally.
And then there's girls who like,
there's a woman who was fighting on the ultimate fighter right now is a very
skilled Roxanne modifier.
She's,
but she's very feminine.
She's very funny.
She doesn't have that fast twitch explosive muscle fiber that you know,
some women have more fallen,
lost a lot of that.
When she started to take an AP,
she doesn't have the testosterone in her body.
I am down with almost everything except combat sports.
The reason being is
because of the frame,
the hands,
the mechanical advantage,
the reaction time and the consequences.
When your physical health,
the consequences of fighting you're,
you're getting hurt badly.
And if there's an unfair advantage and that person uses that unfair advantage,
whether it's taking steroids and cheating by Tate or taking blood enhancers like
EPO,
those are all illegal because they changed the field.
Now there are people that are born with more testosterone.
There's a,
it's a natural advantage you can choose to and not to fight them,
but in this situation we're not dealing with,
we're dealing with a manmade variable,
and I think it needs to be a addressed before you ever fight for sure.
And I think fighting four times or however many times she fought in in secret
like that as a trans woman,
it's very dangerous.
I think it's true.
I understand your point.
I completely,
dude,
I completely do.
And it's a very difficult,
like I'm saying,
for very difficult,
I know as a trans person,
I guess for me.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'm going to give you the example of this.
Let's say I was going to go home with somebody and have sex with them.
Okay?
I am a huge,
huge advocate for disclosure,
so I'm not gonna if we're just date,
where are they hanging out in the bar and drinking?
I don't need to tell you that I'm a man with a pussy.
Right?
But let's say we're going to go home and fuck right.
I need to tell you right now,
dude,
you're not going to get a cock right now.
You're going to get a pussy.
And like that is so important to me that people understand that you cannot put
that other person in that position.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you cannot put somebody in a position of uncomfortability when you bring
them home and they think one thing and you do another big on disclosure.
Good for you.
Um,
I think,
I don't,
I can't speak for this woman,
but I think in her case she wanted to be a woman and she was a woman to make
that choice in her own mind.
What was more important and would people,
how did people find out?
Somebody told on her really got in trouble,
but she's legally a female.
Is she not a,
I don't know where her,
some commissions will accept that.
And you know,
she gets,
her birth certificate was changed.
She's legally a female.
I don't know if that happened with her or whatever.
I don't know.
I think you still,
it's a medical thing.
The disclosure thing,
I think in in some athletic commissions,
being a trans woman is a,
as a medical disclosure saying,
let's say I were to go start fighting MMA,
but I have to that I was a track
that I'm a trans man.
Yeah,
I think you probably would.
I would imagine it depends on the commission because I
don't think people are going to make a big deal out of it as me going in.
Right.
No.
Then as a woman,
I think it's totally different for trans women.
I'm telling you,
they have to deal with this all across the board for the restroom.
The advantage we just discussed,
like your small hand.
Right,
and my giant here.
exactly.
If I just became a woman and we had a cage fight,
I would,
I would have a big advantage just because of the frame of your friends.
A big advantage.
I know it's an advantage.
I know as a martial arts expert my whole life,
what,
how much that plays a factor.
It plays a big factor.
So
it,
so,
yeah,
I know it's,
it's a,
it's a fascinating discussion and of course I,
I do understand both sides.
I do.
Don't,
don't get me wrong here.
I'm going to read.
Can I read it?
Yeah.
Read her statement.
I've been taking estrogen,
uh,
for around 10 years now.
I had my GRS,
her sex reassignment six years ago after GRS mtfs male to females have a lower
testosterone count than even cisgendered females.
This is regardless of if we take estrogen or not,
it's harder for me to keep off that.
It affects my cardio,
my bone density and decreased female range.
At first,
he,
you said muscles will be stronger,
but he backtracked from that.
When he found out he was wrong.
Did you say that?
No.
He said my bone density was a feat in female range.
He backtracked from that.
Awesome.
Okay.
He found out he found that out.
What?
He had been left with his bone structure.
What you just said to me,
that's what I last heard him clinging onto.
He was tron don't,
she's obviously upset about it because you know,
she,
she just has anyway,
he was trying to say that I have a great advantage because of my reach,
but my reach isn't that great.
I was only one inch longer and reach on my last opponent.
My next opponent is taller than me by about one and a half note by one and a
half.
Yeah.
Is it one and a half or 11 and a half inches?
It's likely that her reach is longer or same as mine.
So she,
so that shoots that out of the sky.
Her name is Ashley Evans Smith.
Uh,
wait sir.
Okay.
So then she had me search this video right here with the last,
this woman,
my last opponent thought was Veronica Roth and houser.
She is about six feet.
She knocked out my Ashley,
the girl I'm about to fight in five seconds through either.
It was like a five second knockout.
Uh,
it was the quickest knockout in women's MMA history.
Her bone structure is greater than like 90% of the fighter female fighters out
there yet nobody is complaining about it.
The key thing is they will probably bring up safety,
the safety of female fighters.
If safety is the issue,
then why not bar cisgendered females over five 11
or have reached restrictions?
Okay.
First of all,
there's a lot of stuff going on there.
First,
I never said anything about her or reach.
It's inconsequential.
You win your way in.
You know,
it certainly helps to have a long reach,
but you know,
it also helps be shorter and stockier if you use certain techniques.
I have some are Paul Harris style.
Here's the thing about bone density.
Estrogen is what actually causes bone density,
right?
Causes bone growth.
It's not testosterone.
Men convert testosterone peripherally to estrogen.
This is all coming from a doctor who responded as doctor Ramona cruet sit a MD
and is my friend Steph,
Steph Daniels,
Aka Crooklyn.
Um,
put this a article on a bloody elbow,
which is an MMA website.
I'll cut this worthy.
This doctor was detailing advantages that a male to female transgender would
have because the information that is available online is very biased in a lot of
ways.
And the information is coming from people that are supporting transgender women
competing against,
against cis women as he will.
Um,
so he,
so he have a man who was on a hormonal blockers to block testosterone,
but it's now taking estrogen,
which is going to prevent osteoporosis ostial process.
That's how I say it.
Right.
Um,
so there wouldn't be a great percentage of bone density loss per se.
Males have a higher bone density and higher massive skeletons than females.
And it takes a long time for that to diminish.
Typically,
you're looking at 15 years after androgen suppression and Srs to really start to
see significant changes in bone density.
So right there,
this doctor saying that she has a male bone structure.
Yeah.
We'll,
we may also have,
so we have to cite his research on that somehow.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
But what we sh w where you're showing at least is one person who's an expert in
the field,
a board certified endocrinologist who's telling you that no,
this is not true.
And that this bone density issue,
it takes more than 1515 years and it's a significant advantage that he would
enjoy or male to female would enjoy once she became a shitty right over other
CIS females.
Her testosterone levels are more than likely in the normal female range.
Since her adrenals are the primary source for it.
Now,
without seeing her labs,
it's hard to say for certain.
How are they maintaining her levels?
Are they keeping them at a very high end or the low end and are her normal
ranges for those value?
Uh,
there are a huge normal ranges for those values.
So it's since you're dealing with endogenous or exogenous,
is that what you saying?
How do you say it when it's a artificial hormones that you're inserting in your
system,
whatever,
your,
your engineering,
your hormone levels instead of letting your end to consistent to that.
Right.
So it's very debatable.
Like how,
what are the levels and how,
how it,
how come nobody asked for her levels have that.
They don't,
I'm sure they do.
They do.
Especially now,
she developed fully into a male with a normal musculature
and bone structure.
She,
she didn't undergo hormone therapy and surgery until she was fully developed as
compared to someone who completes therapy and surgery in there,
uh,
adolescents and or era,
early adulthood.
Right.
Men are completely developed by the age of 22 and she didn't start a therapy
until several years later than that.
Right.
So there's also other things that she goes over,
different reasons,
several different,
and we don't have to continue,
uh,
going into it.
But it's a very difficult because of course I'm coming to it from,
I'm a man,
so I should be treated like a man,
whether you like it or not,
I'm coming to it as someone who's supporting transgender and supporting the idea
of gender identity life.
Yes.
It's like,
of course I have to understand that.
You know,
I,
I personally don't understand why she didn't disclose because I would have,
so I don't think probably it's the same reason why she was deceptive in that
letter that she wrote to you about the things that I said.
I didn't say anything.
I didn't dis about bone structure.
Right.
I think she has a higher bone structure that most females,
I didn't disagree about the strength of her muscles.
I don't know what she's,
I look at her,
she's a big woman.
It's a big strong woman and she man handles girls in the cage.
She beats the shit out of them.
Right.
And when I found out that she used to be a man,
I go,
well that's what I'm seeing.
That's what I'm seeing.
I'm seeing,
I'm seeing a ridiculous strength advantage.
And the others girls are strong as shit.
No doubt.
And there's hobby girls,
they could beat her ass.
No doubt.
There's girls like Cyborg that you know,
Shit,
a lot of guys wouldn't want to fuck with their professional fighters when want
to fuck with Cyborg.
But then there's also the Cyborg got pop doing steroids herself.
You know,
she actually inserted some male hormones in your own system.
Right.
My point is if you do want to do something like this,
first of all,
a disclosure is fucking huge and B,
you need to be tested and you need to be tested like across the board on
everything.
You can't just be saying,
I have low bone density and sang,
I have low testosterone.
We need to know what the fuck is really going on.
Right.
And,
and it has to be disclosed if people want to compete against you.
And I'm sure cyborg would have no problem beating the shit out of that check.
Well,
the thing is,
I think Fallon comes to it with,
no,
she's like the first person to ever do this.
So there's a lot of stuff going on there,
right.
So you know,
it is,
it is.
It's a very touchy situation because may she just feels like a woman,
so she feels like I'm a woman.
I don't need to discuss this.
But she started fighting as well.
Now it's different.
I have to tell you,
obviously it's out in the open.
People know about it.
She has a huge opportunity right now to actually open it up for lots more
transgender fighters and figure out how we can change it.
How do we change this?
So it is cool for you to fight and everybody feels cool about it,
right?
Yeah.
How do we do that now?
That's a real good question.
We'll lease now.
It's out in the open.
So now I have no problem with anybody who chooses to compete against her now
just so I don't have any problem with a woman who chooses to compete against
men.
But that's awesome that you just said that.
That's like huge for trans people did for you to say,
I don't have a problem with it,
but how do we do it then?
It's fair because sports is all about fair.
It is.
It's all about there.
I don't care what's not,
but this is not just a regular sport,
right?
It puts your health on point.
I understand.
The reality is she's giving these girls concussions.
Yes.
And the,
the reality of combat sports is not like losing a soccer game.
You know?
It's a strange difference.
A totally different sport.
That's why I get so adamant about right.
The reason why she's so defensive about it is she's got to realize that she
heard those girls.
She knows she actually physically them up,
fuck four or five of them up in the first round and on the first real quick beat
downs,
brutal beat downs.
She didn't take any damage at all in those fights.
One fight,
which one girl hit her with a couple of punches,
boxing.
She did pretty good and she's got her on the ground and put her fucking shit.
Getting any credit for it.
I mean again,
that you're going to credit for her for her fighting skills though there.
Okay.
I know what good fighting skills look like.
I mean,
she's a decent competitor.
You're saying basically that's all come.
She's manhandling them.
That comes from man handling.
It doesn't come from her.
That's what I'm seeing.
What I'm seeing is a huge strength advantage.
I'm not,
and that happens with men and that happens with women too.
There's women that can fucking rag doll chicks and kicked their ass on cis
women.
As you were getting your tee shirt.
I'll wear it.
I get that.
But,
but that's natural when you're,
you're engineering it,
of course people are going to be upset when you're engineering designing,
especially when you listen to this doctor say it takes 15 fucking years before
there's any change at all and that you will have the bone density of a man.
I mean this is a board certified endocrinologist who has no stake in the game,
not someone who's a gender reassignment doctor,
which is what I've read all across the board,
positive in defense of this.
It's all been people who are working in that industry.
Often people who have a vested interest in supporting the idea that transgender
female has no advantages.
Of course they do.
But you can't.
That's fucked up.
You shouldn't be a,
I agree with you on that.
It's about facts.
You have to always look at the facts and if you have actual medical stuff there
that says that this person has an advantage over that,
you cannot ignore it.
It's not being anti transgender.
It's not.
Do you know who,
um,
the,
you know and Renee Richards is,
yeah,
I'm sure it's for folks who don't know.
Renee Richards was,
you know,
basically just a regular tennis player.
Right.
I'm not that good as a man became a woman kicked and was a mother fucker.
Okay.
She was so good.
This is way back in the day.
Women Trans Women had a massive head start on people like,
yes.
She was actually barred from playing as a woman in the u s open in 1976 76
unless she submitted two chromosome will task day.
Right.
She sued the United States Tennis Association in [inaudible] 77 she won the
right to play as a woman without submitting to any testing and she played
between 77 and 81.
She was ranked as high as 20th overall.
And our highest ranking,
uh,
was a,
the end
of her last year in 77 was 20 seconds.
She was a 20th and 20 seconds.
Pretty fucking good.
I mean it's,
it's really an error.
Yeah.
Talia is a pioneer.
She dominated bitches that,
you know what,
like we to break through shit,
we gotta break through shit.
All right.
Listen,
she wasn't fucking hurting anybody.
I different point.
I totally get your point and I think it's valid.
My anger about it,
my,
my distrust in the FFA,
there's a several,
one,
the lack of disclosure initially right to inbreeding her very thing where she's
deceptive in her email and she says a bunch of things that I didn't say that's,
that shows me the way her mind works.
That's a problem.
That's not a good representative of a trans woman.
And then there's also the issue of what the sport entails.
It entails doing violence as quickly as possible and that one 10th of a second
advantage and reaction time is goddamn gigantic shirts,
God damn gigantic.
And you know,
there needs to be studies done as to whether you become a transgender woman.
When does that advantage that way?
Exactly.
Does it ever go is an imprinted right?
Because the issue of imprinting skills as a man and then transitioning to a
transgender woman,
Huh?
There's,
this is not a cut and dry issue.
It's very,
very complex issue.
But what's important is it has nothing to do with heart and love and has nothing
to do with being nice to people is nothing to do my thing.
Mom,
coming from a purely as a a martial arts expert and be a defender of real women,
a defender of real women who gets stuck in a situation where someone might have
a real fucking mechanical,
physical bone structure advantage,
bone density advantage,
testosterone.
Advent is a lot of variables that could really lead to them getting concussed
flow.
ACMA,
not real land that CIS gender.
When I,
by the way,
I remember using rail women freaks people out just to let you know,
I'm,
I'm helping your hair,
but really what it comes down to,
I think it's safety.
Let's get down to the real issue,
especially in a sport that you could kill somebody.
Yes,
and so that is a valid,
that is a valid point I think coming from you.
And I'm not saying that I say it's right what you're saying or it's wrong what
you're saying.
I think it's valid what you're saying and I think we need to figure out how to
make this work for everybody.
Is it possible?
I don't know.
I has the reach make a difference.
It's not reach her.
She said that that's horse shit.
[inaudible] it can be the same height,
the same.
It doesn't matter because you're weighing in,
right?
It's all about the punch,
the contact.
It's about the mechanical structure of the male frame.
It's about the,
the advantage in reaction time.
It's about the imprinting of skills as a male for,
you know,
20 plus years and then transitioning to a female.
There's a lot of issues,
right?
What,
what is huge for me to relay is that I am very to
whatever anyone's gender identity is and I make no judgments on that.
If it had nothing to do with sport and especially my sport of martial arts and
where I'm an expert,
I understand.
I've taught it.
I know I've done it my whole life.
I understand the advantages and they're giant.
You know,
I've trained with world champion women,
right?
You know,
and you,
you could tell the difference.
Should a world champion man in a world champion women,
I'm sure if they're really high level,
there's just a freak advantage that a man has.
Right.
And it doesn't go away.
That easy,
man just doesn't.
Right.
And some women can counteract that.
Like a woman like Rhonda Rousey,
she's his woman as you get and she'll fuck man up legit.
You know,
like world champion men.
She can arm bar then she's legit.
But it doesn't mean that it's,
it's okay trying to make it a political statement at this point.
It's a political statement clearly,
which is not actually fair to do in a sport that could kill somebody.
And what's fucked is I support the political statement side.
Of course you do.
That's,
I know that about you.
That's what's really fun to be on.
Your fucking showed it.
You're very cool with shit like that.
But I can't,
I can't support that because cis women are going to get fucked.
I mean that's already all right.
Anyway.
Not all of them.
Yeah,
the everyone's getting fucked up anyway.
Not all of them obviously,
but do,
I've raced.
Okay,
so I have this question and because every single one of the cisgender women,
uh,
fighters have a problem with fallen a huge percentage.
I don't know if every one I couldn't,
I haven't spoke to every one of them,
but I've spoke to several and I was in private who don't even want to discuss.
It was a chain of expletives.
Fuck that.
And one of the things that they always use is man hands.
These are the size of hands.
If you have a ball peen hammer and a big nail,
it's really hard to drive that Neylon.
If you've got to fucking sledgehammer and the same size nail you boom.
And it goes right in.
There's a weight advantage to the size of a hand that makes a big difference but
entered.
Would it be she's not.
I know,
but that's the problem.
The problem is she's not.
And George Foreman,
if you gave George Short form and female hormones and put them in a dress,
right,
he would fuck up.
Every woman on the planet is handled.
Like don't change your and your hands.
Don't change it.
Don't change.
Neither is your jaw actually to your ability to take a punch.
I mean,
changing from male to a one K,
right?
You're trying to,
your mad face became all like cro.
Magnon Matt,
you liked it though
with a beard.
That's,
you know,
and when in expressing something,
whether it's a on a podcast or expressing something in a tweet or a blog,
some the full idea sometimes always don't get across.
You know,
and I've been accused across the board about this and being transphobia,
transphobic,
you're not actually,
well I think it's really,
it's,
it's normal.
It's natural for someone who immediately point the finger and say that.
But it's not fair to the subject because the subject is very intense.
But you're not transfer.
Not,
I'll say it on air now.
You're not transphobic,
but I'm not anything phobic.
Yeah,
you're not.
No,
you're not homophobic,
but,
but I'll call people on their shit.
That's totally different.
And I do the same thing.
It's completely different.
Well,
I,
like I said,
I'm friends with one of the girls that she fought this cis gendered female who
got the fuck beat out of her and you know,
she was like,
Jesus Christ,
I'm getting manhandled here.
I mean,
that's how she described it.
She didn't even feel like it wasn't an echo fight.
She got rag the rag dolls when you just like fucking just pull shit across
somebody like right when someone gets ragdolled.
Right.
Means that,
you know,
like if you fight,
if I fought Brock Lesnar,
I get ragdolled.
Right.
It's water.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
I'm not saying that the difference between her and a female is probably far less
than me and Brock Lesnar,
he could probably ragdolled me easier than she was rag dolling these women here
in her same weight class.
But there's an advantage and it needs to be discussed and it needs to be
something that's fully explore and maybe she's the pioneer of this flourishes
and maybe they,
you know,
we'll figure out a way to add something that alleviates a certain amount of bone
density.
Maybe they'll figure out how to do something that changes the mechanical
advantage that a man has a promotional thing.
Maybe we have to understand that she has to fight the people that want to fight
her by her.
They have that.
They have that option right now to say,
yeah,
I want to fight her,
or I don't want to fight her,
and then we have to figure out how that's gonna play into this situation.
And you know what?
They're also compete transgender division that may,
no,
that's very cool.
Transgender women,
there's plenty of trans women.
That's a great idea.
That's a super awesome,
I like that idea.
That leaves no controversy at all.
I don't think anybody would have a problem with it.
You wouldn't hear a peep out of me.
I would have no problem with it now because it's a fair fight now.
Yes,
exactly.
And I don't think,
you know,
I don't think there's anything wrong with the idea if it's vetted out and found
to be a hundred percent safe.
Right.
But I have looked at it objectively.
I've looked at the research.
I've been told by all these progressive people that are like,
you know,
hey there's real science been done on this.
I looked at that real science and it's horse shit.
There's not real science.
It's real science that's set up to give confirmation bias to the idea that as
soon as someone is it tanes sexual reassignment surgery,
then they're immediately,
they not just identify as that sex but sex physiologic.
Right.
And it's simply not true.
It's not true.
I'll be the first to tell you that I have female frame still and you cannot
change your DNA that is there.
My frame is still female.
It is.
I can put as much bulk as I want to put it on my body.
I still have and you know when I,
I used to be a lot bigger.
I was like oh getting into the whole body building thing and then all I,
I hurt all the time cause my little frame underneath that was like fuck you.
What is the,
what's the heaviest you've ever got a,
I got about 185 and I was just like,
my shoulders are like this.
I had no neck dude.
I was like,
Oh,
oh as I,
ah,
I'm over this shit man.
And I traveled like mad so I couldn't go to the gym all the time.
I my eating suck.
And so like I know it wasn't comfortable.
My frame underneath my woman frame.
What's going?
You fucking bitch.
I get that shit off.
How much did you weigh as a woman?
Oh,
I was small.
Did I was 110 whoa.
You put on 75 pounds of muscle it on day.
I think a 75 steaks.
One pound,
one of those crazy gym fees.
75 stay packed it up dude.
Like I was crazy.
When you look at it that way,
75 20 grows.
That's a lot of meat you put on those.
What do you weigh now?
Now I weigh about one 60 you felt like that's like,
oh,
I'm at my weight.
25 pounds even feel so Aussie up.
Shit hurts.
What were you doing?
You know a lot of power lifting heavy weights,
dude.
Like every kind of heavyweight you could imagine.
Yeah.
Deadlifts,
bench press,
like all of them.
Big heavyweight that I'm sure changed your frame a little bit.
Yeah,
thank you.
Not just your,
your bone structure too.
I bet that made your bone structure loved dance.
I,
but that's also a lot of what,
how your head got thicker.
Totally.
My nose grew power lifting and especially power lifting under the influence of
testosterone.
That's a,
that's a big one for everything.
Denser.
They say a certain amount of it is actually really important for old people to
avoid loss of bone density.
Men and women.
I believe that.
Totally.
Yeah.
Those power lifting movements like dead lifts and I think they're awesome.
I still do that,
but more than I like crossfit,
he gone away.
Not so much like that going to the gym.
Right,
right,
right.
What crossfit he,
they get a little wacky to now.
They're totally,
those people get bananas.
I have a buddy,
he's got a blown back now from crossfit and I was trying to warn them,
you know,
it's like chill out.
My trainer says that when you do all those reps,
but those power lifting exercises,
it was kinda dangerous yet think are crazy call ups.
They do the w o o d [inaudible].
She opened a crossfit gym and then like totally obsessed with their crossfit and
I go every once in a while and it's all cool,
but it's sexy.
It's insane.
I think those chicks are sexy as far as their bodies look phenomenal.
Phenomenal.
Really strong,
powerful chicks that look like chalk on there head.
They totally are fucking amazing.
So they have
like the squatters.
I should do a porn with crossfit chicks.
Oh yeah.
People would love to crossfit porn.
Yeah.
Crossfit would kick you out every fucking gym in the country.
So as soon as it goes to that true.
As soon as it goes national and big on the Internet,
they'd be like,
what the fuck,
Buck.
Yeah,
you're fucking it all up.
We've got a bunch of people that I've got the total wrong impression of Christ
now.
I think it's a sex club.
Yeah,
you go and squat and then just fucking,
I'm like,
those squats are really good for sex actually.
They are though,
right?
Nobody wants to have sex with frail people.
You don't want to have sex with someone and worry about breaking things.
Uh,
yeah.
So hopefully following is going to be cool about what we just go.
I want Fallon to know that I don't have no disrespect to her as a human being.
I believe that.
And if I knew her only as a trans woman,
we would be friendly as all.
Fuck.
I swear to God,
my issue lies only on the lack of disclosure and what I saw in those fights.
So how can she fix that?
Do you think?
Is there a way that she could sort of,
uh,
you know,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Like sort of,
uh,
bring herself back and,
and,
and people start having a little bit more respect for her in the,
in the MMA stuff,
or now the already lost her disc.
I don't know,
credit herself from that or I don't think anybody ever discredit themselves
forever.
I mean,
I think the biggest fuck ups you,
no one can come back from it if you're honest,
especially if you're honest.
But sometimes people aren't willing.
A lot of times if the community isn't willing to sort of give you,
yeah,
well she's gonna certainly face some resistance.
Yeah.
She certainly going to face resistance as far as opponents,
but at least now it's willing resistance.
It's people don't understand,
not resistance post,
you know,
post fight where they go,
wait a minute.
That used to be a guy,
right?
What the fuck?
And then they get mad.
They're like,
Jesus Christ,
you have a concussion and they can't hear what they're hearing.
That used to be a guy,
of course,
that brings up all kinds of red flags.
You're like,
I'm not fighting a dude.
I'm like,
this is women's fighting,
but that's what now,
now that it's revealed,
I'm for anybody who wants to fight her.
I just think that if the commissions are going to be responsible about it,
there should be some sort of real protocol sentence,
right?
It should really be examined.
Bone density,
the whole nine yards,
everything should be examined and you should have more opinions than these
extremely biased gender reassignment doctors who are providing a lot of the
information that I've been reading online that people have been pointing to in
support of gender reassignment,
people being immediately recognized as cis Joe,
you know,
it's the same real woman category,
whatever.
I think once it's out there,
it's out there.
Now that it's out there,
hey,
you know,
if you choose to compete against her and you're a cis woman and he's got no
problem with it,
it's cool.
I'm free with you trying to ride bulls too.
I think that's way more ridiculous.
I'm free with you trying to fucking do flips on a BMX bike to whatever the fuck
you want,
but any kind of contact sport,
my Imac rugby or something like that.
What do you,
what do you think about if you want to do it as long as you know other and also
as long as the other teammates or people know that you are a transgender person,
it needs to be disclosed.
It needs to be disclosed and it really needs to be studied,
objective Lee and scientifically without any sort of bias.
So we can really look at the actual numbers,
not just in one person but on several people looking on that side,
right?
Yeah.
Pre Surgery,
post surgery in the middle five years and get a real database to work from
because we don't have one right now.
I think,
look,
there's a women,
when I,
when I used to kick box,
there used to be this chick that used to come in the gym at fucking slug it out
with dudes.
Right?
And everybody supported her on that.
You,
you know,
you want to go in there and do that.
And I know girls that are pro MMA fighters to this day that go in the gym and
Duke
it out with dudes and they do it because it makes them better and I am fucking
100% but they know what they're doing when they're going in there.
They choose that.
And just like riding a bull or going BMX riding or anything else is dangerous as
long as you are fully aware of the parameters of the competition that you're
getting involved in and the wrist that they might entail.
Right.
I'm cool with it.
Yeah,
I'm,
yeah.
I just said earlier,
I'm all about disclosure for me and Vinny and [inaudible] and every part of your
life as a trans person,
we're different than the rest of the world and we have to understand that face
value.
I look like a guy,
but it doesn't mean that I,
that I,
that it's okay that you might think that way about me as well.
What's beautiful about today is you may be different than me or you may be
different than Jamie.
You might be different,
but you're not different than everybody and you can reach each other communities
now that can be established through the Internet.
It's,
there's so much broader and there's so much more varied.
There's so much more room for everybody.
You can find those folks.
Totally.
And I think that's a lot of that.
The enthusiasm about finding that is what creates all these weird acronyms and
secret languages and these weird inside talk inside it is,
it's our secret language.
You're inside,
you know,
I think that's sort of,
you know what,
that that kind of fosters that kind of thing.
I think that's a natural aspect of human interaction to make sure,
especially when finally you belong totally.
You know,
you like involve in an engross yourself in it and just really get super in depth
in it.
Yeah.
Because you can buddy up and we all know how we each feel about each other and
know how our lives,
where we all have the same story in different ways.
We all come to it and I think it's also super important that a guy like you
comes out and explains how much bullshit you had to deal with right before that
happened.
And your,
your,
your point of view and how depressed,
how depressed you were and how gross it was to have to fucking fight people
cause they didn't like who you were.
And people can hear that and it will change people's opinions.
I totally think so.
Fuck.
Yeah,
we'll tell him.
But you know,
like I said,
people like you putting me on their show,
I totally give you props for that dude because your fan base doesn't know guys
like me.
And of course they're going to say stuff.
I totally get it,
but whoa.
I know that many of the guys are going to walk away going actually fuck is
totally it is.
You'd be surprised.
At my fan base,
there's a lot of Weirdos.
I'm the,
I'm the bridge between the meatheads and the pie.
Get it.
I tell him,
but that's my point.
That's important because those guys are the ones that are like,
oh well,
um,
they're just,
they just don't understand.
They don't want to understand.
They don't understand also that there's actual strength in not judging.
There's strength in being open this strength and being cool with everybody.
There's strength is personal strength.
Yes,
there is.
And being open to,
to have and not being as secure about that and that closed golf ness is actually
a weakness.
Clearly.
It also provides you and gives you conflict in your life that's unnecessary and
enemies in your life
that are unnecessary.
They easily could be allies.
I know.
That's what I was saying.
Yeah.
Now having the positive energy and discussing those things and understanding.
Remember what we said your opinion about felon is your opinion and I appreciate
that at Penn and she should to my opinion also happens to be the exact same
opinion of every single martial arts expert,
but I've talked interesting.
I have not talked to one had a diff that was one trainer.
Not One person involved deeply in the business,
not one fighter.
Male fighter.
Not One.
Not One said it makes everyone was like,
what?
Cause it's new.
She's not just that.
Well,
and also understand the advantages,
right?
There's,
there's,
there's critical advantages.
Even like great female fighters,
they like Misha Tate is a great female fighter.
She moves like a woman though.
There's a difference.
There's a difference in the way the body moves.
I see that,
you know?
Yeah.
People have.
There's,
there's a real,
like a consensus opinion about that across the board in the mixed martial arts
community and it's almost unanimously unanimously against someone doing that
without disclosure.
Right,
because it's not,
it's not fair.
That's the idea.
Yeah,
because the facts show it's not fair,
but the fact is Serena Williams I think,
or rec bitches,
she's a total cis woman.
I loved her.
You can't even be Serina Williams at an MMA gym.
She would just listen to me.
I would say Serena,
well you're going to be the baddest bitch kill it it Lawson and get but fallen
and her against each other.
Well what do you think that will fall would probably kick our ass.
Yeah.
You need to solve some skills if a person doesn't have any but after you after
your trainer and what do you think about that?
They would have to have a commensurate skill level before you can even judge.
And I would have to like actually see Fallon,
like hit a bag and see what she can actually do right now in person.
You know,
Serena Williams,
I'm sure it doesn't have any MMA training.
I mean to be that fucking good at tennis,
you're eating,
breathing,
sleeping,
eau Claire,
living tests,
but she's a super athlete.
Super.
Yeah.
If she just listened to me,
that pitch and the right gym,
I love her.
She's so awesome.
A couple of years I'll get you the right trainers.
Just listen to me.
I'm going to judge you.
I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to write journals every day.
We're going to take,
she would dominate female MMA.
She kills it more money and she's like,
fuck that.
I'm making.
I look at that body.
Jesus Louisa's look at her fucking body.
God Damn,
I love her.
If you were in a fight to the death with that chick,
you got to fight your dad.
You can't take it easy on her man.
Look at that arm.
My goodness.
If that arm got around your neck,
oh,
you're going to sleep at night.
If someone taught her how to do a triangle properly,
you ever see her legs,
Jamie,
pull up a picture of her legs.
Jesus.
Fuck
the legs of the gods,
the tightness of her vagina and must be a thing of legend.
If she clamped down on you,
it's probably like Doris.
You know a dog is like a,
the male dog locks into the female and the female wants to get away crying dogs
and pain
on pour hot water on them.
There's something physiological that happens to the male's penis where they
actually lock in there somehow in order to make sure,
look at her fucking legs.
Jesus.
Quieter ass dude.
Are you kidding?
God as his mom,
amazing that looks like her ass is pregnant with basketballs.
Look Real.
She guys at light gray out.
She looks like she could just jump over a building.
I mean she is super woman.
She could just launch herself over the entire fucking tennis arena.
What a fucking ass Mike that is isolate ultra.
Ooh,
wow.
Wow.
Where did he get the fuck is that ass?
Look at that shipping out her ass is insanity.
It's a Photoshop.
It looks like a Photoshop.
Photoshop and make sure that's not a Photoshop.
Find other corroborating pieces of that are real.
That's so ridiculous,
but I've seen,
I've seen enough that I think it is what her ass really looks like.
That's power.
God Damn,
you ain't kittens.
That girl,
Jesus Christ.
That girl's got some fucking genetics.
Super Woo.
Like I said,
the amount of pull,
it's insane.
Yeah.
That's on the beach.
It Shit's real.
And that's not even like in the middle of training.
That's just humped smiling with sunglasses are smiling with sunglasses on was
with ultra ass trailing behind her.
That's like three acid.
She has like three small white girl asses packed in together.
Yeah.
That's um,
you can't,
yeah.
You can't get that every day.
If every woman looked like there,
that'd be,
we have it.
We'd be a totally different species of human look at that fucking body.
James asked if that was the genetics of every woman.
We all bread,
we would have warrior children.
We would,
we would make,
like everyone would looked like 300
after they did the CGI on their bodies.
Everyone's body would look like 300 it'd be insane.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
that's in,
that has also the gray area when you're talking about transgender,
it's like that a woman assists gender woman like her exists and then,
you know,
what does that,
that's how freak,
yeah.
End of the spectrum.
That's a gender willing.
So like maybe we should look at what her bone density is and all of the things
that she has in her musculature and then look at,
I mean,
but also the weight class too.
She would be clearly a heavyweight and I,
I don't know how much she weighs,
but I got to fix,
she's a buck 65 at least.
And think about the,
the full spectrum go Molly Ringwald.
Right.
You know,
that's what came to mind.
Pasty red head.
It just looks like she bruises every time she runs into a corner of a table.
Shin bruises and hangnails are swollen,
poor modeling sexy.
I can't see soft and white.
Yeah.
Take her outside and the bright sign she turns pink eye immediately.
Ah,
fucking vampire.
Yeah,
I mean,
and that's the same with males as well.
That's a real issue with men's athletics.
Um,
in mixed martial arts as well.
And that has nothing to do with steroids.
There's people that are just natural super athletes.
And then there's other folks that just have really slow twitch muscle fibers
that wouldn't be bad if they're triathletes.
But in an MMA fight they just can't generate speed and power and then they
fight.
Someone was just boom,
they can just blast them.
And it's sad to watch because you know that fight or a will never beat fight or
be,
you know,
there's fight or being in the ring in the first place cause they're good.
They're just not good enough.
They're good.
They get like there's certain guys,
I wanted to mention any names,
but I'll mentioned the positive side.
There are certain guys that they're never going to beat a guy like Jack Ra
Sousa.
There's a guy pull up his picture of Jocko Ray j a c a r a Souza against you
Shin Okami.
There's photos of him beating the fuck out of this bad ass Japanese dude.
You should know Cami.
No,
you should know Cami is a bad motherfucker and this jock ray guy is such a
physical freak that he just crushed this guy.
I mean cry.
There's certain guys that just have this very unique physical ability and no
matter what you do,
you're never going to beat that.
As long as he's training,
as long as he's learning skills,
as long as he's dedicating himself,
he has certain inherent advantages that he was blessed with that you can't
overcome,
right?
Because if a guy is not just physical,
not just has the physical ability,
but also puts in the dedication and has the intelligence and the mental
strength.
If he has all those those factors,
it's not fair.
Some fair,
right?
Because if you don't have those,
if you just super tough and you're really technical,
but your fucking body sucks a fat Dick,
right?
And you just got some old school slow poke DNA and you just can't get over that.
The physical hump,
that guy can crack you at will and you can't reach him.
You can't get ahold of them.
You can't hit them when you want to.
He's too fast.
There's nothing you can do a pull up,
you get getting.
Is there any photos of John Gray said with someone or just,
well,
just if you find it impressive photo of him and look at,
Oh that guy is a fucking superstud.
It's hard to tell from that picture.
If you see there's a picture of him beating the shit out of Okami.
If you see [inaudible] versus Okami look at Jockey wraith.
Yes.
O k a m I Brazil.
He was a world Jujitsu champion,
multiple time world Jujitsu champion.
And now he's fighting in MMA and just,
and he,
you know,
and he is the argument towards Fallon,
Fox is side that there's a broad spectrum in both sexes as assuming a Williams.
Yeah.
Right.
So then yes.
So does that,
so that's actually a really good question because then you have that,
is that fair?
But [inaudible] yeah.
See if you can find the picture of him beating the shit out of Okami.
Cause there's some photos of him smashing Okami where you look at his body and
just Jesus fucking Christ have you see a move.
It's even spookier cause he moves like a cat and it moves like a big giant cat
just springs on with getting the shit beat out of them in a fight.
Do they like stop it at a certain yes.
Yeah.
It looks like you're going to die there.
You see him?
They're teeing off on him.
But if you see them actually moving it's even spookier.
Yeah,
they stop it.
If a,
if a guy can't defend himself and not defending himself or if the referee thinks
he's taking too much punishment.
Right.
The referee is free to stop at anytime if he feels like it's not competitive
anymore.
The guys with danger and that's the most important job the referee has rescuing
people from danger.
Danger.
Yeah.
Most stores thing that ever happened in a ring.
If someone ever die in there,
not,
not in the UFC.
A guy died this week in Brazil from weight cutting.
Actually.
What's that?
Weight cutting is.
Um,
these guys,
they want to,
there's some fucking,
some dude's arm up.
He's a monster.
He's his Jujitsu is nasty too.
He's a,
he's,
he's a fucking beast.
Um,
a guy weight cutting is like say if you're going to compete at 155 pounds,
you want all the advantages that you can get and one of the best advantages is
you dehydrate yourself.
So you make 155 pounds and then you rehydrate yourself up to like one 70 ish and
then you go into the ring,
they use IV,
so you're going to the rink fully hydrated and you feel great,
but you weighed in at one 55 and now you're way one 70,
so you're really big for the weight class and there's a point of diminishing
returns.
We cut too much weight and it weakens your body so much that you can't perform
well the next day.
And then there's way past that point where this guy went to where he died.
This is the first state cut cause he cut to cut too much weight.
This is the first known case that I'm aware of in MMA if someone dying,
but it's been a problem with college wrestling for a long time and high school
wrestling either even rather to the point where they've started to monitor
athletes weights and how much they cost and how much they put back on and they
make sure that they don't get below a certain amount of body fat.
They're not there.
Make sure that they don't cut too much water.
Wow,
that's scary.
It's very scary and it's even more scary in combat sports because in combat
sports you're also dealing with the effects of the a concussive impacts on the
dehydrated brain and much more dangerous is a little known fact,
but all of the deaths in professional boxing that have occurred inside the ring,
at least almost all of them have been under the heavyweight division.
It's all in the divisions where people had to cut weight.
So then you weigh in at that way,
then you rehydrate.
Is that,
is that legal?
Yes.
Oh it is.
That doesn't make sense to me.
Exactly.
You know why?
Cause you're looking at it as an objective observer that's intelligent and
hasn't already like decided that that's just a part of the landscape.
When you're looking at it normally you'd like,
this is crazy.
This is crazy.
We shouldn't let people do that.
Guy's about the wait.
So that's all you're focused on.
Yes.
There's two different fights.
There's the fight that happens in the gym and or the in the,
uh,
the cage and there's the fight that happens to get to the scale to get to this
cause two different completely.
You can't fight in this year.
That exact
white,
right?
Yeah.
So for the,
the,
the 24 to 48 hours before weighing is horrific.
A nightmare.
They dehydrate themselves.
It's radically hearted.
They don't eat a fucking don't,
ain't shit.
They lead very little food.
There's starving.
By the time they get on that sailors do the same thing,
right?
They have to like,
yeah,
but they don't get head.
They don't have to like smack each other around.
Right.
You get fucking shins bounced off their dome 40 miles an hour.
That's weird though.
Do they talk about this and are they planning on fixing this or there's not much
they can do?
Um,
the one thing that they've done is they've moved the went cause you can't stop
people from doing that if they want to do that.
I'm talking about the actual like laws of the,
of the UFC.
Like maybe they should make the weight in a variable there of five pounds or
something or what you do that because then they would,
people would just get heavier.
They would make sure that they were heavy.
So if you varied it,
if you said like you don't have to wait and one 55 you can be as heavy as one 60
right.
Then they would go get up to one 80 write down the one 16 then they would still,
but they'd still be bigger.
They'd be even bigger because they've got it down to a science.
Like there's some guys,
like the best guys is a Brazilian guy's name is Gleason t bow.
He will cut 30 pounds and he will weigh in holy at one 55 but fight closer to
one 80 he will put most of it back on by the time.
Pull up this guy,
g a t bow,
uh,
g l man.
Try spelling that.
Oh,
you found them good size.
This motherfucker.
If you saw how big this guy is in person,
he's five [inaudible] 10 and he weighs in at one 55 and he's,
he fought antic.
Yeah,
he's gigantic.
When he gets in the cage,
I mean he's a fucking monster.
He's the very best in the world at cutting weight.
No one cuts with better than that guy.
Yeah,
they have it down to a science.
They have to,
it's also biospecific like you might be better at weight cutting than I am and I
might be better than he is.
Some people can dehydrate the shit out of themselves and re and bounced back
easy and cut a lot of weight.
Other guys can't do it and it affects people very differently and no one
understands why.
They don't know if it's a genetic issue.
If it's a diet issue,
they don't know.
But some guys can cut up fuck load away and they do that.
How do they get the weight was a bunch of different ways.
Putting something on some they don't.
They're trying not to do that anymore.
That's the old school way to do it.
And some guys still do it that way,
but that's actually dangerous.
The way they do it now is through distilled water.
They take massive amounts of water up till the way in,
up to the week of the way in and then on several days before the way and they
drank only distilled water and they drink quite a bit of it.
So your body is used to as pissing out this water.
Distilled water is no minerals in it at all.
So you're just,
the water's going in you and are you in you now you're right through it.
You're not retaining it.
And so then leading up to the fight,
they stopped drinking water at all and they piss everything out.
So they get down to like nothing.
Then they step on the scale,
they weigh in at whatever it is.
And then they slowly
rehydrate,
first of all with pedialyte,
which is an electrolyte supplement.
And then they go to Ivs,
they take an IV bag and they'd take it.
Yeah,
it's no joke,
man.
And the Ivy bag is apparently the best way to rehydrate your noggin because the
brain,
the brain fluid is the real issue.
And doing it through the digestive tract,
apparently it takes much more time for sure than it does a through the right
into your blood and can rehydrate much quicker.
Right.
This is the size of this guy to glace and tee ball.
Yeah.
I think,
I don't know which one is pre way in.
That's the one on the right is when he's dried out.
It just looks like the same muscular guy.
Just a little smaller it looks like.
Yeah.
And then on the left he just with the white shorts on,
see the size of that motherfucker.
He's a tank too.
He's a strong mother fucker and he's also a black belt in Jujitsu.
All right.
And he's got like 30 fucking plus MMA fights.
He's a beast,
but he's the best at doing that.
But it's a dangerous game the way it's really not cool for your brain to do
that.
I've seen guys walk up to that scale where they look like they're dead.
They will,
they struggle to get the weigh ins on the top of a platform and they have to go
up this platform but go up the stairs to get to this platform.
I've seen guys who are going to fight in a cage in 24 hours and they can barely
walk up those stairs.
Wow.
Barely make it
real dangerous.
Nothing they can do about it.
The best thing they've done is move the weigh ins from uh,
the day of the fights to 24 hours before boxing did that.
And then what does that do?
It gives them more teams,
more time to get into the ring because they used to do with the day of,
they used to do it the morning of the fights.
Guys used to weigh in and then they would go and fight that night and weight
cutting and has existed forever and boxing and wrestling and you know,
and as soon as MMA had weight classes,
people started waking up out of air.
It's always,
it's,
you know,
because especially with MMA because MMA,
they came into it with a wrestler.
It's a mentality and a lot of MMA fighters,
their bases in wrestling and in fact it's the best base for MMA and those guys
that came into it or used to cutting way,
right.
They're really good at it and they don't know how to do it well.
The issue of course is that their sport doesn't have head trauma or much head
trauma,
whereas MMA is all about,
it's all about that.
Yeah,
and head trauma with dehydration,
I'm surprised that hasn't been more death.
They're on the ball.
The doctors are excellent.
The referees are excellent.
The commissions,
they keep a close eye on fighters and they test the shit out of it before they
actually get into the cage.
They make them do Mris,
a full full blood scan.
They make sure that these people that go in there healthy and they've actually
found a lot of like real issues with people because of these scans that have,
you know,
like people didn't know they had like an aneurysm ready to happen in your brain.
If they got hit out.
My friend Dan Hardy,
who was a top level MMA fighter found out he had an extra heartbeat,
some weird aberration of his heart ways get his primary heartbeat and he's got
this weird sort of extra beat that goes on and the worry is that this extra beat
can
overcome him and he could possibly have a heart attack.
Right.
I don't understand the medical aspect of it,
but he can't fight now unless he has his operation where they go into his chest
and remove this extra heartbeat.
Yeah.
You can't fight now.
And he's a top level pro and it's just the concern by these athletic commissions
and the doctors have,
have kept him from,
uh,
from competing.
So he hasn't fought in the UFC and a couple of years.
It's a real issue.
Why does he get an operation?
Well for him,
he doesn't feel like he needs it.
He doesn't feel like it's warranted,
unnecessary and fighting.
It's also he underwent,
and I hate using these terms,
but in his case it's actually the correct term.
He underwent a spiritual transformation.
He uh,
went to uh,
uh,
the Amazon and took Iowasca and sort of his reassessed his entire life since
then.
And uh,
it was really not totally had an awakening.
Yeah,
he's totally fine.
Zahn but it's,
it happens if you take it.
And also I think those things happen.
Oh yeah.
I really believe that it happens.
Have you ever done Iowasca but I,
I would be pretty awesome to do you need to do it?
I think so.
Yeah.
Well,
I've done the strongest version of it,
which is the pure dimethyl trip to me.
Oh my God.
Get the Amazon and he didn't know I was at my house.
And you're painting an all Amazon go where the bugs are.
That's ridiculous.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Where are you are one of the things he realized when you do DMT is the earth
gives zero fucks where you are.
While this is happening,
you do not need to be in the desert is way bigger than that.
It's the whole universe.
No,
totally.
Wow.
Dimethyltryptamine is the pure version of what the Io Osca experiences.
Iowasca is the orally active version of dimethyltryptamine and these shamans in
the Amazon figured many,
many thousands of years ago.
We don't even know when they figured out how to combine these ingredients in
order to make DMT orally active.
DMT normally is not orally active because it exists.
It's so many different plants.
So many you would,
you would be tripping all the time.
Right.
Salad,
really no bullshit.
So your,
your body produces something called [inaudible] oxidase and monoamine oxidase
breaks down dimethyltryptamine in the gut.
So what they've done with Iowasca is it's a combat,
a Tory drug where they've taken the route of one plant and the leaves of the
other and the leaves are a,
or the root.
One of them is a natural Mao inhibitor and uh,
it's called harming.
And they boil this stuff down together and they create this thing where the Mao
inhibitor and the DMT or all together.
So that as you drink it,
it goes into your gut.
But the mano aiming oxidase gets killed by the harming and the DMT goes right
into the bloodstream.
Yeah.
[inaudible] it's like a slow release version.
When you go to the spirit world.
It's for real.
The idea of the spirit world sounds like everything that everybody
thinks about.
When you think of like if you took a pill and you went to a magic place where
there's dragons and demons and aliens and spaceships and fractals all around
you,
it's that times a million plus plus it's way more real than reality itself.
And Yeah,
and well Dan Hardee went down there and did this and a,
he's like a few tile.
It's like Kinda like,
what am I doing?
Like what is the,
what's the necessary evil here?
What is the what,
what,
what?
What is really being done here?
What is,
what am I really pursuing?
And he realized that what he's,
he was basically on a vision quest.
His life was like a vision quest and to to find himself to seek truth.
He did it through combat.
You know,
he did it through physical,
one on one competition and the most dangerous sport in the world.
And then in having this Iowa,
and I'm,
I'm really speaking out of turn to put these words into his mouth,
but I think what I got out of it from speaking to him was that he,
now that he understands that this whole world exists and that it exists,
existed always,
and it was behind the curtain that he couldn't see the little man behind the
curtain point of chords.
And then all of a sudden he saw it and he sees everything.
He saw the whole thing that he's just,
his perspective,
it was altered so radically.
And it also coincided with when he was diagnosed with this condition.
So it's almost like the universe is giving them a new planet.
Totally is.
It totally is.
I'm a big believer of that.
It's possible.
I mean,
it's possible you create it all yourself inside your imagination as well.
There's many things out there that are possible.
Yeah.
If you're helping to me,
Oh yeah.
Have to be open to it.
Fuck yeah.
The imagination itself as scary as fuck.
That's why people aren't open to it.
Yeah,
I look at that.
It can just freak you out.
Imagination is madness.
Just what it is.
I mean,
everybody thinks that the imagination is being,
Oh,
you know,
he thinks about things that aren't really,
they're sort of,
but the imagination is also what made cities,
it also,
what made the laptops,
they made every physical object that has ever been created had to be invented
and it had to be invented through the imagination.
Even it was done in steps like first came the tire and then came the wheel and
then came the engine.
All those things combined created a car that gets you to Vegas.
That's a real thing.
You know all those created a plane that gets you in the air.
All those created a fucking spaceship that launches a satellite into orbit.
All those created a phone that allows you to text someone who's in Australia.
All those creative light bulbs,
all,
I mean,
all that shit is imagination.
Imagination has reshaped the entire surface of the fucking planet.
Like no other thing.
Entity.
I didn't know no other power more so than fucking volcanoes cell after he had
that trip and he doesn't fight anymore till you find that he found that he was a
different calling for him right now or I don't know.
I haven't talked to him in a while and then we need to get it back on here.
I don't know what he's up to these days.
Interested to know like he feel like with that
his fighting was over and it was time for him to go to a new path and that's why
he wasn't really worried about having the surgery and going there.
That make sense?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
look,
I think he probably would still like to compete every now and then if he didn't
get it worked out.
But I also believe that what he was saying was that that's not the most
important thing in the world.
And he also realizes how much of the goals that he wanted to achieve where ego
based ego centered share.
And one of the things that gets crushed when you have a really intense
psychedelic experience is the ego ego.
It always bounce backs,
bounced back a little.
I fight with my ego all the time.
It was every man does.
Of course.
It's part of like it's a part of it.
It's also part of the testosterone thing.
It's part of something x,
y chromosome thing.
It's part of the Dick thing.
It's part of the male identity thing.
You know,
there's a constant need to feel special,
you know,
to justify why you're doing what you're doing,
to do,
to reward yourself for what you've done.
And I encouraged further progress but that progress,
I mean that's,
that's what sort of like sort of pushes forth almost everything that men do in
this world.
And there's that weird balance where you're trying to,
you know,
be a,
uh,
sort of a enlightened person,
but also you're a man,
you know?
And it's like fighting against that.
It's fighting.
Yes,
but I prefer the term struggle.
Okay.
Right.
We're not even struggle,
but like it con is you constantly have to be aware of it.
You constantly have to be on alert and make sure that the Eagle never pops up.
You've got to constantly,
cause you know,
if you're under stress or if you're not diligent with your exercise and
meditation,
you can allow your thoughts to get away from you.
Oh,
in La and take over.
And then my other question was going to be,
so I find it really fascinating that you're saying that because I know women and
men think totally differently and I can tell you that,
right?
Sure.
Right.
My thought process changed the way I interact and people don't tend to realize
that.
Why I think men and women always have problems with each other in relationships.
Men's needs are different than women's needs.
And it's a reality that people don't want to talk about.
It's true.
It's like this.
Do you think that that is true?
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean I assume it's true,
but it's true.
It's true.
And I think a lot of problems could be solved in the world as well as
relationships.
If people just are okay with that and they don't fight against it,
like the woman needs these sent things necessary for me to be happy in this.
And then the man needs this.
And it causes this huge conflict within that relationship,
whatever.
If it's a friendship or a marriage or whatever.
That's also with friendships too.
I mean,
some people require a lot.
A lot.
Yeah,
and some people don't,
and the people that require a lot don't hang out with them.
They're not worth it.
They're never worth it there.
Now you're telling me,
right,
they're never worth it.
I don't care if they have golden pussy or Magic Dick,
whatever.
After a while you're going to get bored.
No Way.
You have to feel like you're both getting that,
situate that and the people that require an exorbitant amount of attention,
exorbitant money,
they're out.
They're never worth it.
Way in the long run.
You're going,
I dated this girl once and she was so fucking dramatic.
Everything was a struggle and everything was against her and everything was
about her.
Everything that went well for someone had to be turned around to highlight how
bad her life has gone,
including things that would go well for me.
It would immediately turn into woe is me because I don't have anything good
going on in mine.
It was so brutal.
And we broke up and then I started dating this other girl who was really nice
and it was like I got an a balloon that was flying around the city and this
other girl was like friendly and she cracked jokes all the time and everything
was funny to her.
And I was like,
Oh,
crime,
any,
there's hope in the world.
It's like my soul was on a balloon,
like up,
up in a way.
Beautiful.
But she connected with you now.
It wasn't just her being a woman.
I think there was a connection,
but the crazy one was better than people level.
The crazy one.
Batteries.
Crazy,
wild pitch water.
Fuck.
Like,
like a dog.
She wanted to just distract herself from her miserable mind.
So she wanted us to wild,
crazy fucking hair,
pulling madness.
She just wanted a growl.
That's pretty honest with the other one was just a sweetie,
you know.
And then again,
it's the balance of the fucking crazy world we live in is totally 100%.
The,
um,
the other problem is not just the men who,
you know,
who think that they understand how women think and the women who think they
understand how men think is the people.
The other problem is the people who pretend to be someone else to placate the
opposite gender.
Oh my God,
that's so huge issue.
It happens all the time.
Those are the White Knights?
Yes.
The male male bitches of the world.
Well this guys who get together with like for example,
I have a obviously stripper friends.
Obviously I say obviously because I work in the sex industry.
Of course they have stripper friends and then like the guys get with the girls
and they don't want him to strip anymore.
That's hilarious.
It's all the time porn stars to right and points nurse can't do that anymore.
Like what the fuck is that all about?
Yeah.
Or they make weird rules like you're allowed to fuck other people but only or
you only,
it felt how difficult girls in front of me.
Only girls in front of me.
Or you can only fuck like a short list of guys that I'm friends with.
Exactly.
And they can't come in your face and we're going to get real specific
penetration on one woman,
Bro.
It's really,
that's ego stuff going.
It is.
But you know,
they say,
you mean if you,
if you really pay attention to the heavy duty psychedelic heads,
they say that at one point in time
when people regularly consume psychedelics,
we were much more like chimpanzees.
We had this orgiastic community,
small group,
you know,
50 to a hundred people and we all shared in fact,
um,
one of the guys that we have on the podcast all the time,
it's a guy named doctor Chris Ryan and he wrote a book called sex at dawn and
it's a fascinating book about the origins of human sexual interaction and his,
his take on is really,
first of all,
it's really well studied.
These,
uh,
secondly,
the,
just the origin of words like promiscuous,
the original origin of promiscuous doesn't mean like having sex with random
people.
Like that never happened.
It means mixed,
mixed sexuality,
like having sex with several partners.
That was promiscuous,
but it was always people in the community.
It was always people that knew each other.
Right.
Cause there was only 50 of you and you're hanging out in the Amazon,
you know when you're shooting darts at monkeys and trying to stay alive and keep
that fire lit.
Right.
It wasn't like going to a club and picking some strange guy and letting them
come inside you.
That didn't happen.
They didn't allow strangers in the camp.
You know,
they didn't,
they didn't just go meet people and fuck.
Right.
It's like polyamory or something.
Yes.
It's also the idea exists in fighter pilots.
I was another really fascinating aspect of this guy's books that fighter pilots
and people in intense high risk,
high death rate jobs would often wife swap.
And the idea of the psychology behind it was the wife swapping was to ensure
that they're the one that they love so dearly.
It's not that they didn't want to have this connection only with them,
but they wanted other people to love them too because they probably wouldn't be
around.
Ah,
wow.
That's really fascinating.
Yes,
and it's very common amongst fighter pilots.
Like this is a switch that goes off when you're in this intense,
you know,
the odds of me dying or very hot odds of you dying,
or probably 30% or something crazy like that,
so I just made that up.
Then I know why it dropped 30% I had to define it.
That's what,
that's the,
that's the ego
having to come up with a number,
but that they do that on a regular basis.
That's a super common thing among soldiers.
Some police officers,
a lot of pickups wound up doing that and they totally do.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
That's what it's about.
It's about this.
There is a primal need to have your loved ones loved by others so that they'll
be safe when you're gone.
Wow.
That's really fascinating.
Yeah.
The human,
human sexuality morphs so much dependent upon circumstance tell,
you know something.
People don't,
they just think,
oh,
that's why people want guys especially need to go out.
It's part of your DNA.
It's part of,
you need to spread your seed.
It's very normal.
I think that guys go out and need to have sex with lots of different people.
I think it's part of explaining that to my wife or anybody I know.
I'm just kidding.
But you can't eat,
be okay with that if you did that or would she not be okay?
I think she'd probably be pretty sad.
Really?
Yeah.
No women don't want you to go fuck other guys or other girls
now you can't be fucking,
you can't,
well you don't want them to fuck other guys and they don't want you to fuck
other items and even if your DNA is telling you to go do it,
you know,
I know some people who are totally okay with that and they have a bunch of
strippers and free established this.
I know all the polyamory people who fuck each other.
I think um,
every man would certainly want that.
If it was a one way street,
but I think most men will.
Would you be okay with your wife fucking someone else?
No,
that wouldn't be nice.
Yeah,
I wouldn't enjoy that.
Now you're living in China when if you watch,
my question for you though is because you were a woman and now you're a man.
Right?
How has your thoughts on that changed?
You were always a lesbian though,
identified as a gay woman for my ears because I was the only thing I knew how I
could identify though I felt like a man.
Then when I told my lesbian community,
well,
I kinda feel like a man and I'm going to have this change.
They all got me.
I lost all my friends.
They were like,
you're a trader.
Basically.
They said,
I'm a trader.
Why?
Going to the bad side?
Wait a minute.
That was the actual,
oh yeah.
I actually said,
you're going to the other side totally dead.
And I was like dumped.
Wouldn't you think that people who have been marginalized,
I think that forced to just tow it up,
all sorts of prejudice and hurtful things that they would be more accepting.
You would think that that's a very good point.
What is wrong with,
well,
I guess 20 years ago,
I don't know if so many lesbians feel the way,
but I think that there is this whole thing going on in the gay women's community
where they feel sort of,
I don't know.
I actually,
I can't say anything about that because I've always wondered why they don't take
up real estate the way that gay men do.
Like gay men can fucking dominate an entire community.
It's a male and a male and female thing.
It certainly is of course the,
the,
the building of male communities,
like gay communities.
Yeah.
It's like they're like,
Ooh,
it's that.
It is like men need to do,
women are really much more passive and they're fine with that and they're fine
with their situation there.
They don't need to be making a big deal out of it.
I mean,
I know that you experienced prejudice and hate as a woman who's a gay woman,
but I think it's less so than gay men experience.
Yeah,
because they're less out there.
Right.
Like I just said,
that gay man are out there making that statement where the gay women are very
comfortable being in their environment and not really making a big deal.
But it's also like if gay women moved next door,
it wouldn't freak a lot of people out.
But if a gay man that interest or they would start going,
oh,
he's going to try to fuck me.
That's what it is right there,
man.
Totally.
Oh,
men don't want to feel like a a sex object.
I want to feel like they way they treat women,
but I think some men to other men,
if you're a straight man and you're like,
no,
that's not totally cool and you're not,
you're not affected by the gay women because you might want to watch the gay
women have sex.
Yeah.
The game women are no
problem at all.
It's not a matter of fact.
Try to be friendly.
It's fine.
I get invited over for the pioneers.
I'm just quiet here and it can be buds.
Well listen man,
this is a great conversation.
It's really,
really fun.
I'm glad we had it and uh,
I'm glad we covered,
you know,
so many of the various aspects of,
uh,
the,
the world of transgender and gender identity and a,
I think a lot of people got a lot out of this.
At least I'd hope.
I think so.
Yeah,
I think it was a good one.
I think he's a,
it's a super important subject and it's also super important that people can
understand that,
you know,
it doesn't matter man.
People are people,
whatever the fuck they want to do,
whether it's be a man,
be a woman,
you know,
get all tattooed up like you and I or not,
or shave your head or not,
or fucking whatever,
man.
Just what kind of interactions are you having with that person?
And my interaction with you was very pleasant.
I enjoyed it very much.
So we're friends now,
they're pretty cool.
I'm friends with buck angel go bitches.
All right.
That's the end of the podcast.
If anybody wants to find you online,
they can get you at a buck angel on Twitter.
Um,
and you have a website.
It's a buck angel.com and is what's the best one of those things.
Dot Qaqc,
angel.com there's a contact and all that stuff later.
And um,
uh,
in Twitter's exactly the same.
And Facebook.
Okay.
And,
uh,
let's do this again.
Oh,
sweet.
We'll do it again.
Beautiful Fun Times.
All right.
Thanks everybody for tuning in to the podcast.
Thanks to squarespace.com go to squarespace.com use the code word Joe and the
number nine and save 20% off or limited time.
Might just be a jeweler,
but you'll save 10% either way next month or whatever the fuck it's worth it.
Get a website,
bitch.
Don't be cheap.
Um,
the end support support people who support us and lumosity.com,
um,
is also a our podcast sponsor,
the newest,
latest and a fascinating podcast sponsor.
Um,
a literal actual site,
literally an exercise station for the mind.
Really interesting.
Um,
games you can play that actually enhance the way your brain functions.
I'm trying them,
I'm not smarter yet,
but I have hope,
lumosity.com.
Tell him that you heard it from me,
Joe Rogan.
And,
uh,
thanks also to [inaudible] dot com use the code word Rogan and save 10% of any
and all supplements.
The next episode will be the great 400.
The 400 podcasts spectacular would be off 400th episode.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to get jiggy with it.
We're bringing in Joey Diaz for sure.
And uh,
hopefully,
uh,
a lot of the rest of the,
the local posse,
the entire freak party.
And,
uh,
we will,
just get as many people in here as possible and we'll all get lit up and we'll
have a good time.
It would probably be a big sloppy drunk mess and stoned and probably forget what
we're talking about halfway through and I'm sure is going to say something
really stupid and it's going to be excellent.
And I'll probably wind up being an animated thing online.
Uh,
so we'll for sure see you guys on Friday,
most likely.
See you before that as well.
So until then,
big kiss.
Wow.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Okay.